[Music]
do
no
[Music]
so
how i
accidentally became the biggest
chess streamer of all time me
how is that possible
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
oh my god let's get a photo
we got a photo booth right here and i'm
like
i don't really like taking photos uh
i saw you big man hey yay
[Music]
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what wait what i want a refund
can i stop my wife
and as much cash as you can carry you
can keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and put them
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken
paul champs competitor here
oh my
[Music]
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knight's
moving the angle you're stepping up the
mack then you straight
[Music]
and we are live we are here it's pog
champs 4 presented by coinbase with me
the one and only alexander botez we did
it alexander we're here another pog
champs is set to begin
i can't believe we're here danny i
remember pogchamps one as if it was just
yesterday this is such an awesome event
and i can't wait for us to get started
with the latest edition
and like pogchamps one we had we had no
idea what we were really in for and we
we haven't really known ever since right
every edition is different
every every grouping of variety
streamers and celebrities gives us
something special and on that note let's
meet our 16 participants for the first
time officially as we kick off the show
i a lot of familiar faces a lot of brand
new faces alexandra let's just let's
just pick one off the top someone who
who you're super excited to see maybe
someone who we we haven't seen in a
chess tournament before
absolutely well i will say that i'm
excited to see how sapnap is going to do
in pogchamps because i've been really
impressed with his chest performance
over time i hosted a couple tournaments
together with my sister for minecraft
and chess and he was just killing it
learning really quickly and this is
going to be his first time playing in
pogchamp so excited to see how he's
going to perform yeah for sure it'll be
see how it'd be interesting to see how
he's building there's so many other
people building on on their chess
performances ludwig coming off his hot
twitch rivals win a rematch versus mr
beast is is not too many days ahead
harry mack is someone who i'm just on
the edge of my seat to just i'm just a
huge fan i'm gonna fanboy out when
harry's playing today so i'm super
pumped to see what he's doing and five
up five up is now no longer a hidden
mass streamer like now people see his
face so that's
that's
wild right yeah and on top of that i
mean five up was so sharp during among
us i played a lot of games with him he's
always putting the clues together
figuring out who the imposter is so i'm
really excited to see him use his
tactical mind to win some chess games
and of course we have the the spanish
xqc as he's known um he'll be he'll be
the uh the only one i don't think he
likes that danny he's not the spanish
sqc he was the og he was there before
and he's huge
just just saving your butt there a
little bit you are saving my butt and i
i did it on purpose let the controversy
begin trying to get chat to go to get to
get on it about that one but all right
let's move on into the format it is of
course the format that we've been doing
here for for a while for pog champs the
players are split into four groups so
quads or pools if you will you get three
points for a victory uh outright in a
match two points for a win in tie breaks
and one for a loss if you make it to tie
breaks and and don't uh don't overlook
that because when it comes down to who
moves on to championship and consolation
brackets every game counts and sometimes
we see those who made it to tie breakers
go that much farther uh it's a 10-5 time
control two players advance to the
championship bracket from each each
grouping and two go to the consolation
the prizes alexandra uh we've we've come
a long way from the first pog champs and
we've got a whole lot on the line of
course for charity but first thing uh
everybody everybody playing each group
stage winner gets 2k
and uh just for being here there's 3k on
the line um so
exciting there 20k is more than i have
ever been paid to do anything in my life
not so much for you alexandra but for me
i would love to compete in a pog champs
and win 20k
well on top of that it's also super fun
content they get to play chess against
other streamers and it's always nice to
make things competitive and have a prize
fund on the line and i know that's not
the only thing on the line um i really
love that you guys have been partnering
with charity as well so that there's you
know good cause while people are
enjoying the entertainment
yeah we're super pumped this is the
first time we've actually had podcamps
focused on one charity last time our
participants chose their own charity
this time we decided to go with a
particular cherry this charity that
spoke to us rise above the disorder has
helped tens of thousands of people all
over the world receive mental hair
mental health care free they're all
about affordability and accessibility
which are usually the two major blockers
for people getting getting the the help
they need when struggling with with any
issues in terms of mental health
rise above the disorder is uh is here
throughout the whole event for those who
want to get involved you can go to
go.chess.com rad and make a donation
jess.com will be matching up to a
hundred thousand dollars donated to rad
we hope to to blow past that um and and
raise even more so obviously a big part
of bringing everyone together for these
events is to do good things and we hope
that hope the community will kick things
off right here today with me and you
alexander let's do it let's raise money
for rise above the disorder and uh
and have a good time doing it let's
let's move on to the pairing shall we
here we go i i uh we got croakies and
the original the we'll just call him the
og and rubius he is the third most
followed channel on twitch for those who
keep track of that kind of stuff and uh
what what do we know about croakies
alexandra he's a cranky scottish magic
the gathering player
and he is super sharp on top of that so
he has been hardcore training chess over
the last 10 days he's gained something
like 200 elo points in that time frame
he's already almost 1200 rated however
rubius is the one who does have more
experience from the previous pogchamps
so at least it'll be a little bit more
level out in that sense yeah i'm really
curious how this goes i don't know how
much uh rubius has been training for
this but i know he's been doing private
lessons with
uh with anna rudolph and so i know that
he's i know he's ready and i i like you
and anticipate he's gonna be
a much stronger player than in pogchamps
three but i did a lesson with croakies
last week and he is sharp you're right
and he's he's got he's got a critical
thinking approach to everything he does
and he's been grinding this week so
gonna be interesting to see we'll kick
things off with that then we have the
reigning block champs champion versus
harry mack i think i think sapnap's
favorite in that matchup just knowing
that harry is really just getting and
falling in love with chess
but um what has snapnap been doing to to
build on his block champs victory here
well i don't know how much chesty has
been training i know he and my sister uh
do lessons every now and then which is
awesome um and he is really sharp at
tactics so he used to do quite a few of
those
also he is the favorite so maybe he
didn't prepare too much for harry but
that might be something he should be
careful about because you know harry is
the underdog but sometimes it's good to
be underestimated yeah and the last
matchup of the day is going to be cutie
versus conor that's actually a rematch
of pogchamps 2's consolation bracket
where cutie sent conor home by a score
of 2-0 but that'll be that'll be oh no
2-1 i think she she beat connor in in
the pog 2 consolation bracket so all
right that'll be interesting let's let's
go right into our
our uh presenting sponsor they have put
a lot behind this event we are super
pumped to have coinbase bringing
bringing uh their support to pogchamps
and uh like we said yeah pogchamps is
presented by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered visit
coinbase.com chess and get five dollars
in bitcoin right off the bat just for
joining it we're gonna you're gonna be
hearing a lot about coinbase throughout
the whole event also alexandra because
for the first time we actually have an
event running for the community by our
sponsor while you're watching pogchamps
you can join an arena and the cool thing
about arenas is even if you're late you
can still join and you have a chance to
win the coinbase community cup is
running as soon as the games began for
our for our viewers to have something
even more even more to do even more
engaging use the command coinbase cup
and uh figure out how to join if you
if you want to do that
and it says do you have what it takes to
be a pog champ so what do the winners
get if they participate in the arena so
we have premium membership prizes
everything is sponsored by coinbase and
uh there may also be some random drawing
prizes based on participation i'm gonna
i'm gonna check in with the team on that
but we're we've never done a community
event from a sponsor before and so it's
just something something more for people
to do i know when i watch chess it makes
me want to play chess then i play bad
chess and then i stop playing chess so
that's my that's my pattern some people
might watch chess and then play chess
and play good chess so they keep playing
you know hey i totally get it i get the
same way inspired to play and what i
like about arenas is that um you know
maybe at the first you'll get a pairing
that isn't super leveled but then you
start playing a lot of people who are in
your rating range and you could do
really well even if you're not the
highest rated player because of how
arenas work on chess.com so for anybody
who has a chess bug while watching
definitely would recommend joining in on
that
all right well we're gonna take a very
quick break when we come back it's the
pogchamps bug that's that's biting
everybody it's what we're going to be
doing here for the next couple weeks i'm
so excited that day one is finally here
when we return it will be the first
moves of pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase me and alexandra we'll be right
back
[Music]
do
no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
so
[Music]
and we are back with croakies is it fair
to say you're the most well-known magic
the gathering human being on the planet
um no
what one of them nowadays maybe about
over
rumor has it
they will make you a magic the gathering
card true or false
false i thought
i'll try but
we'll see
it's possible to get magic cards but
well maybe one day
well you have been really quickly
improving in your chest we were talking
about how you gained something like 200
points in the last 10 days i know you've
been grinding really hard but do you
think any of your magic skills translate
over to chess
i mean i think it gives you somewhat of
a good foundation but it's
it's not going to get you
deep into chess but it's it's a similar
strategy game i've played a lot of
different strategy games not not only
magic and then i mean i think it gives
me a solid foundation to work with and
it makes me confident that i can learn a
game like chess over time but
uh it's not going to get you the whole
way
yeah and the confidence is a huge factor
for chess a lot of new players are
intimidated when they get started but it
seems like you're not intimidated at all
how are you feeling going into your
match against rubios who does have
previous experience playing in pogchamps
i mean i enjoy the process of like
learning new stuff in general and
especially
like a game like chess it's i like
strategy games i've played them all in
my life really so i'm pretty comfortable
with the process it takes to learn these
type of things especially a deep one
like like chess but
i'm i'm confident about the match um
a little more confident today than i
would have been a week ago but um
yeah i'm feeling good i'm ready to go
but you told us i guess those watching
at your channel and everyone should go
follow croaky's twitch channel right now
heard us heard what you said but so
you've been you've been playing a lot
you had a couple lessons you've been
using openings for but did you did you
do any specific prep for rubius
obviously you can see his games on
chess.com are you are you are you
feeling ready for for what he's going to
throw at you or are you just focused on
on your improvement
i'm mostly focused on myself just
because i know i'm gonna have to play
against a lot of opponents but i've had
a quick look and to try and see
what he likes to do
and um
i don't make any specific
training to get ready for playing
against rubios but i have a little bit
of knowledge about how he likes to do
his openings and stuff like that and i
think i'm comfortable with what his plan
is
you're so level-headed you remind me of
you know grand masters when they give
interviews and they're never giving too
much away they're always there for the
learning experience the result doesn't
really matter uh i i i like that killer
instinct yeah or not
the result
is for sure you want the 20k what are
you going to do with the 20k if you win
pogchamps
um
that's a good question
i'll probably buy something from my
newborn son
get my nice
well to be honest i don't know i've not
considered any 20k presents up until now
but i'm sure i can find something
well now everyone is going to root for
you that is just too much of a wholesome
answer right danny that is a that's a
sweet dad sweet dad answer i could use a
new twitch shirt too by the way if that
if that happens i'll talk to you about
it because i need i need more swag
all right man well uh we wish you the
best of luck we're told that uh i think
rubius is also
ready he's been just chatting chatting
away but i think he's ready so good luck
and uh
i'm sure we'll be catching up to you
more than once over the next couple
weeks so have fun and uh we'll see on
the other side
okay
all right bye man
all right let's remind everybody that
while you are watching you can also
collect epic clips we also want to thank
our sponsor eternal for helping us
create that
eternal.gg with eternal.gigi you can
support your favorite streamers by
collecting and trading their best gaming
highlights the same way you collect and
trade pokemon cards by the way i miss
you pokemon sign up now with your twitch
account to participate and
look for a limited pack drop on
september 12th
each pack will contain some of the best
moments of pogchamps and all the
proceeds this is important go towards
supporting rad the eternal is an awesome
sponsor obviously they're doing super
cool things with the the different clip
packs you can gather but if you engage
in any any proceeds and and revenue
gained from the whole process is going
to supporting our charity rad and we're
super excited about that
before we jump in and start following
the games one more shout out remind you
where you can follow us on all the
places that chess is followed you should
definitely follow our discord for this
particular event alexandra the
the pogchamps discord for this event is
uh has some special stuff going on you
can our sponsor coinbase is giving out
diamond memberships during the
tournament and so if you're not in the
pogchamps discord channel use the
command discord don't miss out go win
some premium memberships and we'll see
you on our discord channel if you if you
weren't already there you're missing out
i have a game versus the world where i'm
losing right now which is torture for me
um
so now another reason to join you can
beat me and get premium member
memberships from coinbase so
all right sure and what i really like
about discord is that you can really
keep in touch with other people who are
watching the event i know my community
uses it for our twitch channel and it's
a really cool place to hang out if you
ever need to find a sparring partner for
chess who you also review games with or
something like that discord is just
awesome so hope you guys get in there
all right well we are
we're ready i just i i feel i feel so
nervous when the event first start can i
just say that sometimes i feel better
when i just admit that i'm nervous
alexander so i'm just gonna admit it i'm
nervous
yeah no it's totally fair um i think
your nerves are going to soon be
replaced by excitement it always gets
super exciting at when the game start
and i'm sure you remember that from when
you're competing
yeah and uh i a little bit of nerves is
good like you said cause when you're
competing it can help bring up the focus
we see that croakies is focused we're
going to we're going to tune into him
while we take our last and final break
before the games begin so don't go
anywhere when we come back we will legit
have the first moves between croakies
and rubios in just a few minutes
i need to reel them in
and then i'll unleash the beast
i came across as someone who was trying
to come across as that
i'm red
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on
eternal
these sometimes hilarious always epic
gaming and irl highlights directly
benefits the creators while providing
you the fans something unique and
special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
and we're back the players are
ready to rock we're gonna be uh
we're gonna have we're gonna have action
here on the chessboard in just a second
and that's that's when
that's when it's exciting because we
have no idea what's about to happen and
rubios is ready croakies is ready are
you ready alexandra
i am so ready and uh i guess maybe this
would be a fun time to talk about
predictions i know you did some training
with croakies and he was talking about
how he was going through chess.com's
opening trainer the other day uh
how do you think he's going into his
strategy
i mean i i i went over a bunch of
different openings as they start here
with him and tried to do that thing when
you only have one lesson with someone
you just try to give them a map right so
at least they're looking at the forest
with like some roads rather than
oh my god there's just a bunch of trees
here right so we did a lot of that but
he was super sharp and on top of it um
he play he plays the queen's gambit so i
was super proud that he's not a london
player can we just have a huge win for
one less london player on the planet i
mean right there yeah my sister is
crying a little bit but it is okay and
they are off and i love how it looks
like they have the hair on the opposite
sides of their body yeah and then you
also have the color too right croque see
has the black hat and then the the red
beard on the bottom and then rubius has
got the black it's actually kind of
aesthetically pleasing to see them going
up against each other like this yeah it
is the uh the way they're they're
mirrored and also opposite personalities
rubios has not stopped talking i don't
think croakies have said a word
super focused
and rubius is also the underdog and
talking is going to make his life a
little bit more difficult but so far
he's still pretty comfortable into the
opening theory it looks like croaky is
playing some kind of catalan i always
find it risky to let your opponent grab
a pawn
before you've really started looking
into opening theory because the
compensation you get is so strategic and
difficult to figure out that maybe he'll
just be up a pawn for a while
i totally agreed and i and i oh wow and
now b6 is played by rubios i gave
croakies that advice and we ended up
looking at some straight up queen's
gambit accepted and i i talked to him a
lot about just playing the safe ways to
bring the bishop here but he was
he was ready to play the catalan and i
don't know how well he knows the opening
it's actually i knew he played it was
the one thing we didn't look at um
so
why don't we
when we do the thing we do let's take a
look into rubios and watch a streamer
who's language i don't speak and just
see what happens
[Music]
alexandria he's all over it he knows
what he's doing
where is the other voice coming from
[Music]
but yeah i heard it when we first
i know we i know we
never know what we're in for but can i
just say this is a straight up queens
gambit declined kind of position to make
you know to make chess masters proud
this is natural development and
i don't have any real criticism for
either player at this point in fact
rubios has not only stayed with the
catalan which is an odd opening
alexander for his level but he's up on
time
yeah absolutely and the position might
get a little bit trickier soon as the
center opens up
because both of the bishops are going to
be facing each other so that is
somewhere they could look for tactics
soon he plays c5 so he's bringing yet
another pawn into the center here uh
what advice would you give for how to
start calculating which pawn to take
that's a great question by the way shout
out to our first north of 50 donation
beak doc just donated 50 bucks we
appreciate it raising ronnie for rise
money for rise above the disorder um
okay
usually there's the basic chest math
which is just how many attackers and
defenders does each side have but what
you want to do is try to visualize the
end of an exchange if i was white i
actually would be looking to take a
couple times here because at the end of
that position we have i can even just
show it real quick we have a hanging
pawn structure where both of these pawns
are potential targets for white to do
easy moves like bring the rooks to the
center and at at this level of chess i
feel like it's more than likely these
pawns will be will be undermined and
targeted rather than what it takes to
play with the hanging pawns which is a
lot of very accurate kind of developing
moves so um
but anyway that that's interesting we
now see rookie one has been played
though
it makes sense
because uh you know one of the options
you can either take or try to hold
detention so he's slowly improving the
position of his his pieces and it seems
like rubius is really speedy he replies
right away puts his work on e8 but
sometimes that's a bad thing when you
play quickly and reactively
yeah i agree
i
i'm just like really impressed right now
though i'm sitting here like wow this is
the game that both sides have a pretty
good idea of what they're doing and
again we don't know what ruby has did we
know that our girl anna has been
crushing coaching i feel like she's
coaching everybody this year rubius i
you know christine uh christina you've
got her working with justin minx but she
must have
knowing anna she must have given him
some advice against the catalan i feel
like this is like rubius is too on top
of it here
yeah i mean anna's certainly a fantastic
coach but at some point they're going to
be out of opening theory regardless and
a move like queen c2 shows that he does
have a very good understanding of how to
get started with openings he is moving
his queen up off of the d file so once
it opens up he can bring his rook to d1
he's connecting the rooks and that's one
of those developing moves that's a
little bit less obvious just moving your
queen up one square
we saw croakies sit back and put his
hands up let's see what he's saying for
the first time
he's jamming i was gonna say catch him
this is good focus music actually
can we get some emotes of people
jamming out to the tunes here yep
some party parrots
prefer music hat jams there you go there
you go
well he he leaned back and said
something maybe time to take this though
there he goes
the right idea
it is good that he's starting to
calculate the takes um
do you think he should be worried at all
about a move like oh
never mind okay so he's going for rook
d1 which i like because he's keeping the
tension and that is always harder to
play against at this rating i like how
danny's bobbing his head you guys can't
see it but he's party parroting with you
guys
this is i feel like i just got could
have went through the first they're also
pushing the sponge not too bad so
take take attack the bishop
okay i agree and again
it's a compliment to the players
alexandra that they're both willing to
play with the tension it's one of the
hardest things to do in chess i mean is
to is to see a capture and rather than
break it is to build on it right as i
say that a capture is made but i think
at the right time today this is if you
waited one more move as rubius the next
time white captures here all three of
these pieces are unleashed to the d-pawn
and you probably lose it so it was now
or never and he correctly realizes it's
time to take
um yeah this is actually a great move
and if e takes d4 rubius can also take
on c4 and create an isolated pawn on d4
and on top of that he might actually
have some chances to hang on to that c4
pawn yep
no for sure this is this is not the the
normal setup where it's easy to just
regain that pawn
so oh wow croaky stuck with the knight
which is
i i think even if it's like debatable or
roughly equal according to the computer
i think that's the right tactical thing
to do in this position he opens up the
bishop this is how you're going to get
someone to blunder by creating that kind
of tension for example rubius if he had
any plans to take before now he can't do
that now you just lose right
because of this
yeah no it's super tricky and even if
let's say rubius takes the knight with
his knight he won't be able to capture
the pawn on c4 because his bishop on b7
is hanging through so there's so many
pins going on here on the long diagonal
as well as on the semi open d file now
this is
if this is any sign of what we're in for
for pog champs for this this could be
the the the high the highest level blog
chance we've ever had i mean this feels
like a game i could you know switch the
names and i'm looking at theory between
utah grand masters
um yeah i'm super impressed with their
level of play so far and also the way
that they've been both managing their
time so very similar amount of time um
they're not playing too slowly and oh e5
just played on the board so the reason
you are always very careful to push your
pawns is they can't move backwards and
now the d5 pawn is attacked three times
it's only defended once so it looks like
he blundered upon here because it is a
couple moves ahead so it wasn't the most
obvious tactic to see right away
yeah and it's hard one of the easy one
of the easiest things to mistake as a
chess player is when a piece has been
defended all game it sort of becomes
like just subconscious in your head that
it's not a problem right you're just
like okay like you're not you're not
checking anymore the tactics as you
should and so then you make a move that
otherwise seems aggressive and safe and
just forget the obvious that you're
you're undefending something that was
critical so
your move knight takes was definitely
the best move um
but okay now we've seen the trade and
probably croakies is going to win d5 but
this is still
okay krogie's is going to be up a pawn
but let's look at the clock rubius has
maintained himself to this point
this still could go it could go any
direction i think
yeah um
any direction
but if c takes d5 in particular and
croaky ends up getting that past pawn
this is gonna give him some of his best
chances here although if he ends up
pushing it too far then he won't be able
to protect it with other pawns so yeah
you're right rubius might be able to win
it back and when you're at this rating
range a pawn isn't the end of the world
it's not like a grand master when they
get upon they start celebrating because
they're like wow i'm going to squeeze
this positional event
okay bishop b7 is a good move if black
plays rook c8 you get the you get the
rook here you still have some potential
maybe to advance this pawn open the
bishop
i think croakies might want to just push
the e4 pawn and reinforce that
okay and right as i say that he does it
this is even if it's not objectively the
best it's the safest thing to do and it
kind of makes white's position really
easy to play with that extra pawn
right and rubius he has the bishop pair
here but it's going to be in a closed
position so they're less useful and of
course he's also down that one pawn i
wonder if croakies knows how good his
position is here yeah let's let's listen
in see if we can catch first of all i
need to work on my scottish accent it's
one thing i'm really struggling with so
any extra time i can get with croakies
on camera is helpful we won our pawn
chat now it's time to
convert
there you go he knows what's going on
croakies is on top of it
and again that was this is great great
great
i just the scottish act i mean do you
have a scottish accent
i can push this pawn
i can push the on again
although it seems
like potentially i hear him louder than
i hear you
okay
and i don't want to cut off croaky
because i really want to hear his
thought process here i mean queen v3
looks like a great move if that's what
he's going for
it's also just kind of good doesn't it
okay there's a copy past i'm guessing it
from croakies it's about how watching
croaky has made me a less productive
human being a worse chess player and
dare i say a less considerate lover but
he did get me to buy a big ass water
bottle and for that i'm grateful
who is that person and get get them a
diamond membership please asap that was
the great coffee pasta
that was amazing
oh man
look at this movie croakies is
here to play man this is
good stuff
but there he goes pushing his pawn to
the point of no returns it won't be able
to be protected by any other pawn
i can escape
queen if they keep pushing these puns
he's got a great a great uh background
there with the chess pieces scattered
for this oh for sure sorry i'm a visual
learner um
all right let's go back let's go back to
the board here and highlight what he was
just saying because it is it does show
that he's he played d6 alexandra like
you said this poem will either be you
know great strength
or great or great weakness i just i just
flipped the board that was really cool
um but he was highlighting the idea of
freeing up the d5 square which i think
i think is good although what's funny if
you play a move like knight d5 it's
exactly the way you can just lose this
pawn
and surprisingly the knight has no good
discovered attack so that would be
right it looks like you'd have knight
takes f6 to take the bishop with check
in that position but of course the queen
could recapture the bishop that being
said it could scare off rubius and make
him think that there's some kind of
discovered defense so it could be one of
those ghost threats that you end up
being afraid to take a free pawn even
though there's no backup there yep
oh he did it
he did it queen d5
well you called it will he
will he will he see the ghost you know
whose ghost he's going to see the ghost
of uh alexander botez the botes gambit
oh no it's not a boat it's not even a
real beautiful gambit but i do love that
oh the way the emoji just popped up on
top of the board i remember i think i
used to do it myself in obs like two
years ago just for the memes i'd
sometimes add funny pieces on top but
look he did it
he played queen takes he did
all right now now does rubius think this
is a brilliant tactic or is he worried
that he blundered his queen um i don't
see him arrowing the knight idea yet
nice job
[Music]
all right a little distracted by the cat
that keeps appearing over the beat where
that is an incredible alert
yeah
that's gotta be i wonder if there's like
any kind of rankings like the top sub
alerts on twitch that's gotta be top
five
top five is is really
a tough ranking i feel like there's so
many cool twitch streams out there but
from the ones i've seen you're right
it's amazing but the the animation
obviously to me i like to go with the
simple sub alerts you know
but um but if you appreciate the
animation look at this
wow what a game right now black is right
back in it
and rubius has the bishop pair
so
yes white is better with the knight on
d5 but given that he's no longer down a
pawn
i this is going to come down to a time
scramble so it'll be interesting to find
out right out of the gate which one of
these guys is going to do better with no
time on the clock
right and i see croakies hovering his
mouse over the knight on e3 and he
talked about d5 so he's probably going
for it um
and and then he's also gonna be
attacking knight c7 with a four
okay he changed his mind
this is this is really really helping
ruby is here this is the kind of thing
that yep
is easy to do this bishop h3 idea and
take that croakies did but
it's it's really not um
not actually improving his winning
chances here
yeah because it it he actually helped
develop his numbers get it on there
in the corner it just doesn't it's not
doing anything
okay but rubius needs to see the fork on
b6 and play a move like rook c2 putting
his rook on the best square possible
attacking the pawn on b2 and then his
position looks better
or even what he did here rook to c6 not
about that's also great yeah not not not
getting forked your move was definitely
better but any idea that stops the fork
rubius says this guy
has come a long way already just in the
last five months since pogchamps 3.
um yeah i mean do you remember what his
rating was in the last pogchamps when he
started off i think he was around
600 or so
um and i thought he made a pretty big
climb
yeah and it's also hard to keep up with
chess and not get rusty when you haven't
played in a while um so he obviously
must have been training because he's
playing this super well but as you said
it's going to be a time scramble he is
up about 30 seconds right now
uh it could be anybody's game which is
what we like to see
someone said 1200 in ireland is a
thousand anywhere else i think he's from
scotland though isn't he scottish that
must have been was that a double burn
first of all if you're making whatever
that would be some sort of racist joke
at least get the country right
yeah no i i read it out because it was
funny for the content and then i i
realized it was the wrong country
i'm calling out the person who was
chatting that was hilarious
although it's like when you call
canadians budget americans and everybody
just gets really angry
it's
which is saying asking him how's the
weather in iceland
um
and uh oh he's irish he is irish
weird okay or bad
wait he is irish he is actually irish
but no he's not irish living he's irish
living in scotland i think
oh man we're gonna need to get a fact
check on that this is like
got confused with zelda for the first
time
wow that was a throwback um we're really
just making this worse and worse aren't
we daddy let's but look at this by the
way look at how rubius is playing he's
up on the clock
sticking sticking with his higher rated
opponent and i and i know that rubius
has been working a lot he hasn't been
playing as much
i'm getting debated i'm getting debated
oh my god stop trolling me chat
gosh darn it okay he was right right he
is scottish
chad just loves debating get out of here
okay i made a mistake no worries
okay
by the way ruby has played
bishop e7 and f6 right away but bishop
e7 threatened bishop b4 at first i i was
about to literally clap my way out of
the room everyone would have been
thrilled oh my gosh look at how rubious
is playing this position
he played bishop e7 and then played a
bad move
but bishop e7 to come to b4
is ridiculous what a monster seriously a
monster yes
he he's trapped in the 90s
we're about to see an upset here and
will it be an upset by the end of the
turn i don't know i mean maybe rubius
has just been sitting there grinding
away secretly on chess but
oh hey at least in terms of the rating
this is an incredible performance for
him he is beating somebody who is 300
points higher rated than he is um
very strong start for rubius
and uh it looks like croakies is is
really leaning into this trying to
figure it out seeing if there's any
last-ditch efforts okay but he's
probably figured out by now
there's his best chance maybe he can get
a pawn yeah i was gonna say his best
chance is to bring the rook to a8
and trade okay you see he sees this idea
looks like he's about to play it
this is this is a very good move
he's still in this game
yeah because if he that's the great a
great pawn to grab as well because now
he's creating an isolated pawn on b5 and
if he somehow gets that pawn and he has
two passers it's his best shot to fight
against a bishop even if it's not
even if it's still losing at least it's
a good chance
yeah and i like this
the reason it trades it off is that you
don't like it but i was worried if he
attacked it rubius was going to play b4
and then
they're really going to be stuck
though at least they only have an
outside
that's fair that's fair and i know when
you're down material you'll not find our
way through
you're just trying to find whatever you
think is most tricky and this could be
tricky because at least he got the pass
pawn right away the difficulty is if he
pushes a five now and the rook goes to
a2 it's on a dark square and it'll be
hard to protect but he does have that
check in store
brings the king to e6 now
threat here uh oh a5 the threat here is
a move like bishop e3 or bishop e1
rubius doesn't see it but if he and now
he sees bishop e3 which okay this move
is
rubius's chest right now is through the
roof this is an incredible fine smile
look at that smile that is
[Music]
okay seven that's a good move
okay
[Music]
he saw it good job good job
oh my gosh he literally almost broke up
there
within drawing territory for croakies
i'm still recovering from that bishop
however take it with the king
if he does it
rook oh no oh no oh no
if croaky sees work f7
oh god oh my god
[Laughter]
but i think i heard what he said kids
ear for me
take your king put it towards the pawn
it's your best shot it's your best shot
he can potentially still get a draw
what so he is technically losing this
because the white king is going to use
the white is going to use that outside
passer to distract the black king take
the e pawn and then go get the side pawn
thank you for arrowing danny and uh
rubius is gonna be too slow to bring his
king back for that drawn position but if
croakie misplays it then he has a chance
to save it oh gosh rookies needs to get
the king up before going any further the
main point is you got to get to this
pawn before the black king can get back
and see i'll move like that i move like
a7
one one
if he does that oh no there you go there
you go now now rubius can draw it i mean
this is this is a very instructive end
game actually
it is and if rubios just brings the king
back it's actually a very well known
draw
because you can't win with a corner palm
when the when the enemy king okay the
shoulders
end i'm gonna be upset
oh no he thinks he's winning and he's
gonna feel bad
he's gonna feel like he choked even
though it's a drop but again rubius
needs to find it and come in with his
king and a lot of beginners don't study
end games because they think it's not
important so it's very possible he
hasn't done these lessons but anna his
coach is an endgame savant
accept the draw
no thank you well and the nice thing for
for rubius alexandra is
oh
right as i say that he
maybe does go the wrong way but it's
very it's very hard to mess up even
though he has his king in the center all
you have to do is bring your keys closer
but okay we're about to see a really
critical moment right here
if the pawn pushes from croakies
oh sorry i was looking at the delayed
board
yeah here he has to play his king to f6
yep and he did it
oh no
here he might make a mistake if he
doesn't move his king up and he moves
his king backwards he's going to let the
white king escape
yeah you have to keep the king
shouldered
he didn't shoulder the king here oh my
god he didn't and he left the
passenger that's so sad because he
played it so well he played incredible
man in this game we went from rubius
playing like a grand master
to
[Music]
if he plays queen c7 and king a8 that's
some oh don't play king c7
taking his time
yeah the croakies is stumped he doesn't
he doesn't
the triangulation is confusing
it's actually really instructive for the
viewers it's why you just want to put
your queen to trap the king on the edge
and don't try to do it the way croakies
is doing it because you risk stalemate
with every king move you make
yep it's it's pretty intense i don't
know do you think croakies is going to
pull it off chat what do you think pipe
draw or win and do it before we have a
result that's why you can get social
validation i forgot to do this
vote now or forever hold your p vote now
and we'll see what you said in chat can
you predict it here i have honestly no
idea it's going to be a stalemate or a
win just make the box smaller man
just to make the ball now he's finally
got him accidentally on the edge and
he's going to deliver checkmate there we
go
he did it and i actually saw a lot of
draws in chat at least half
at least half
which is cool c chat he pulled it off he
over performed
congratulations to croakies for this one
ruby has played such a good game yeah
it was actually not that obvious of a
blunder and he was in time pressure when
he made it
yeah and
and you made a really good point we'll
just show it real quick back here is
that this is the lesson when you bring
the king over
you want to shoulder the king and keep
the king here but instead it's very
tempting to go after the pawn which is
exactly how you can lose these games and
we see the evil eval bar pop up
now the king is not in a position to
stop the queen so
man and it is intuitive to just put your
king next to the pawn but whenever
there's a pawn on the edge of the board
you want it
you want to trap the king yep yep all
right well our first game is in the
books what a wild turn of events it
wouldn't be pogchamps if we didn't have
an eval bar bouncing all around given
giving you a heart attack so we will be
right back with the second game between
croakies and rubios don't go anywhere
pogchamps 4 continues and just a momento
[Music]
so
bye
[Music]
so
and we are back getting ready for our
second game of pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase let's remember that you can
earn crypto by learning about crypto
that's pretty awesome you can learn
while you earn visit coinbase.com get
five dollars in bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account as long as
you're a real person you get free money
that's is that what they're telling me
if you're a real person you get free
money
yeah but then on top of that coinbase is
just one of the easiest places to buy
krypto on especially for people who are
new and getting into it so really cool
sponsor yep
man well here we go with our next
potentially really cool game i i'm still
just
yeah kind of shocked
ireland versus spain really excited to
see our top irish streamer here battling
the spanish
ireland versus no i think this is
ireland versus xqc isn't it isn't that
what this oh yeah let's really offend
everybody danny i'm sure that's going to
go really well
it's not like rubius watches our clips
anyway
uh that's true that's true we're not
cool enough for rubius to watch but uh i
would yeah
i'm gonna let you get clipped out of
context and i'm gonna be the one being
like oh danny i don't think you should
have said that mate yeah exactly you'll
be the one on on everyone shares my
clips i get in trouble for stuff i said
on shows like weeks ago like it comes
back to bite me i'm like oh i said that
like it literally happened recently i
won't say but someone's like yeah you
said this and i was like no i didn't
then someone showed a clip i was like oh
man i actually did say that that was
awkward um
yeah yeah the internet is forever but
that's okay it's going online
nothing you can do all right
by the way steam coming out of his
nostrils he's ready for the rematch he's
how is he so positive and smiling after
that i have no idea many good vibes
we might need to reset his clock here i
i don't know if he knows he's probably
not going to be killed when he finds out
did you twerk on on stream before i'm
getting word from the producer that
you've twerked on it may or may not have
happened
if you if you can't clip it you can't
prove it um wait he can't move
he cannot move his pieces uh oh oh he
needs to
he needs to refresh or something i don't
know tell him to refresh
uh yeah sure let me just dm him i'm sure
he'll reply to me uh yeah no it's not
gonna work but we'll get the producers
or somebody to help
find the clip chat oh yes find find the
twerk
uh just kidding all right so going back
into the game uh rubius needs to win
even a draw and he's gonna lose the
match luckily for him he has the white
side of the pieces which might not
matter so much you know when you're 900
versus 1200 but i think it gives you a
little bit more confidence because
people tend to have more experience
playing with white
true and
okay there we go the game has been
aborted apparently
um don't worry chad while you're waiting
there's a great clip of danny in the
chat that you could check out for your
entertainment purposes
the game started so here we go
um okay we have an alapan sicilian and
nothing nothing in chat to check out
there's nothing there all that matters
is this um
okay so this is already the first moment
where as a coach everyone has these
moments in pog champs where you're where
you're you know did i look at this with
my student we actually did look at this
and i showed him what to do and it was
not to play d6 so unfortunately croakies
went against my
went against my advice against the
alpine we actually talked about this and
we talked about playing d5 because the
whole point is you're trying to punish
the fact that while white wants a big
center with c3 it slows down the
development of the knight and this is
this was just the most principle way i
told him to approach it
the problem with this approach alexander
is now you take on d4 and you basically
have just given white a huge advantage
in any sicilian so of course at this
level there's a lot of chess to be
played but croakies we're going to have
a big talk after this
you and everybody else in ireland we're
going to go over this
there you go well
rubius does have a very nice center
position and this is a pretty
straightforward opening to play now too
because he just has to get his night out
bishop castle but once that's out if he
does end up pushing one of the pawns or
anything like that it's not like he's
gonna hold on to his big center forever
but i guess the best way to try to use
it to his advantage would maybe be
something like bishop c4 and
considering tricks like knight g5 i
don't know i sometimes like cheesing
opponents what do you think about that
danny well
the
okay you're like i'm a coach i'm gonna
say don't play bad chess don't choose
your opponent play bad chess hoping for
bad chess from your opponent yes that is
what i'm legally required to say um but
i but i hear you okay the problem with
e5 is this is the
you have the center you want to use it
but
it's not that's actually how you lose it
so in this case if you use it you lose
it in in the case of the big center and
it's not a good idea the queen trade
helps black a lot that was not not the
right approach you want to you want to
sit on this big pawn chain put your
pieces here
get castle put your rooks in the center
do fun things
in this case you now lose the center by
trying to do too much with it and
croakies is right back in the game
okay and the queen trade uh so now
they're going more towards an endgame
position here and it seems like they
were both somewhat similar level in
endgame we saw them both trip up a
little bit over the last one which is
fair because it's hard to study all of
those when you're just getting started
but now i'm concerned that rubius gave
up one of his center pawns so he had
that beautiful center early on and now
he dropped one of the pawns yep
gonna make my life harder with croakies
because really hard sometimes to
convince a student that they didn't play
well if they win they're like no matter
what you say it's like yeah yeah yeah i
won okay back off right but this was not
the right start
even though okay and now bishop c4 is
kind of concerning because now he's
going to have a doubled pawn if prokise
plays knight takes c3
which is going to end up being a target
later on and if you see something like
b6 bishop b7 putting the bishop on a
long diagonal but i like that he's
trying to develop because he is behind
in development so maybe he noticed that
and
in that case it's good at least he's
getting some of his principles out there
anything could still happen
yep there he goes writing that hit song
alone in my principles and taking on
these double pawns but um
although the thing is he's also at a
disadvantage because he's lost his last
game so he's going to play a little bit
worse because he's still recovering and
there's just not enough time in between
he has more pressure and he knows he
can't even draw and he's down a pawn so
he's going to feel the pressure to play
crazy
this is a good move though right
preparing rook to c7 it's the natural
thing to do
um
[Music]
but yeah this is
the problem i have with with the
position for white is that it's
one of those positions that's also kind
of hard for black to blunder right now
like as long as croakies just makes
natural moves it's hard for me to put a
piece on a square as black
that that loses something and takaru
always talks about that like a
blunderable position like this is like a
very easy position for croakies to play
and that's what makes it hard to
to play to play rubius rubius aside here
right
but at the same time once he gets his
castle in
um
maybe it'll be somewhat
cleared that he still has a lot of
developing moves and in that time span
hopefully
croaky pushes some pawns and creates
some weaknesses because otherwise
it's gonna be a very tough uphill battle
here yep
all right so everyone's developed
everyone's having a good time um
just is everyone having a good time i
was just reminding chad in case you're
wondering chat you are having a good
time here so you're welcome yes you guys
are having a great time chad we
appreciate you being here
you are having a great time you're
having a great time relax and close your
eyes
all right
i like that
hypnotic chest stream that's the next
thing that's the name yeah we're trying
we're trying ireland you become better
at chess if you just believe
yeah the jedi you are in a winning
position you are having exactly um
exactly i like b3 yeah
because
he can move his knight now without
losing the b2 pawn so very solid play
here yep e3 is a good move
again like i said i think it's kind of
an easy position for croakies to play
and he does one of the rook moves that i
was anticipating and but i agree so 93
can be played now and that's the first
chance for croakies to go wrong because
you really don't want to let that trade
happen and double the pawns opening up
the g-files so good move there you go
all right rubius is bringing it bring in
some pressure
that's exactly what he needs to create
chances somehow he's also up by two
minutes on the clock i see croaky
hovering over this the knight on c6 um i
wonder oh it looks like he's gonna play
knight before
which would be really good for rubius
who could then take the bishop well i
guess he can't he has to he'd have to
play rook a1 first get rid of the knight
and then take the bishop wait he doesn't
he doesn't want to put the work on a1
because you've got this this guy back oh
yeah sorry i'm sorry
no it's i i think we were right i think
you should take it and forget the a pawn
everything just looks kind of okay
though
because of what croakies everything
looks kind of okay
yeah but he can still take the bishop
here and then just move his rook out of
the way and he has some counter chances
and he's
hopefully gonna see it
has that nervous hand position going
nervous hands he's either just put
lotion on his hands which it is great to
take care of yourself and have soft skin
but it's usually not good to do that
while you're using a mouse
so we're either gonna have to go here
with the bishop or
or take the bishop maybe
look at that
thinking about exchange sacks to pop a
pony on d3
five head chests here
i'm trying to not talk over his uh prep
but man that is a huge water bottle
i mean even though it's been
coordinating
yeah i mean
like i said i started watching his
stream i've been less productive
i've gotten worse at chess i've become a
less considerable lover but now i'm
gonna get a water bottle and i'm going
to be hydrated all the time you've got
one thing going for you overly large
water bottle
exactly exactly
you haven't really made it on twitch
until you have
a
water bottle you can't fit your hand
around like that's the sign you made it
right and you have huge water bottles
too danny so i'm sure you can relate
here yeah you can have a huge gallon
with me somewhere but
oh man but the castle was not a good
move
um he really needed to grab that bishop
now the pawn on h3 and the pawn on a2
are both hanging and on top of that he's
not going to be able to uh take the
bishop open up the g file and get a rook
on g1 putting pressure towards the king
that was the kind of attack that really
could have given him the chance to swing
towards his favor here you know and it
really was real to show real quick if
you had taken f5 here as white
whether you take here or not it doesn't
matter at some point you take here and
this rook comes to g1 this is this is a
real dangerous position we saw the eval
bar jumping up and that's because white
could have also taken with check but
that that wasn't the point just showing
that when this trade happens it was a
real chance and
often if you're losing chat you want to
be willing to to risk even more to
create anything that's unbalanced the
last thing you want to do is go down
material and then make it a logical safe
game for both sides for the rest of the
day right you want to create dynamic
chances and
rubios might have missed his opportunity
to do that
all right and bishop d3 is another good
move by uh croaky here he's playing this
super well i love what he's doing
because uh if bishop takes knight takes
sure rubius can take um on c8 after but
then he'd be activating the rook
bringing it onto the open file and then
he still has to take care of his bishop
which would be under attack on f4 so the
best move ruby has found is to just try
to move away but now
he can try to trade off a little bit
more which is in his favor given that
he's up upon bishop takes c4 and we
heard him previously talking about how
he knows simplification is a strategy he
can use once he's up
yeah
he's uh he's all over it ryzen what
lubwig said at the end of twitch rivals
as soon as he's up a pawn he's looking
to trade now as players get better or
more experienced in chess they really
just appreciate
the art of simplification right i think
when you're when you're first in the
game you want pieces because you think
of you know i want the queen on the
board i want pieces but then the better
you get the more you appreciate your
ability to kind of strangle your
opponent that's kind of graphic but
that's really the truth right the moment
you have an advantage in chess it's a
game of math and you just want to
strangle strangle the game away and and
take away all the life
wow that got really graphic
and that's just gotten more that's like
a murder mystery one
we are missing a murder mystery within
chess when is that gonna happen like
queen's gambit two
a murder mystery you know like some
famous chess player
is killed or something really bad
happens i mean
they did drive bobby fisher crazy danny
they leave clues on the chessboard
you know yeah maybe clues maybe at some
point someone figures out that if they
if they go to the perfect square
uh oh god we're talking about murder but
look what's going on here oh my gosh
that oh this is rough there goes the
bishop
i i feel bad ruby has played so much
worse his second game yeah he did you
can tell that his performance impacts
[Music]
all right
it's actually a very tough skill to
master to not let your
play level drop too much after a loss
but i think it's one if if rubius worked
on and if he wasn't so hard on himself
because everybody has mistakes like that
he would get such better results um of
course it's easier said than done and i
am a huge tilt queen myself and i don't
even know if it's possible to control
but
definitely a skill i think the two of us
need to learn yeah it's
no i think even at the highest level
right the highest level they are better
at it than than everyone else and you we
always say you want to have the the
memory of a goldfish right two-second
memory the happiest creature on earth
um
right but it's easier said than done and
uh even for the best players in the
world you have a you know a
vulnerability hangover after you lose a
game you feel vulnerable and and i i get
those a lot for over sharing owner
vulnerability you ever had a
vulnerability hangover alexandra next
day you wake up i know i said too much
that night
yeah yeah after these shows
no no yeah i i know what you're talking
about danny those um those are always a
little bit concerning uh
and i don't even it might be a
personality traits too for people who
just get really bad guilt after they do
things like that um and if that's the
case then it's really hard to fix
but yeah i mean seriously in chess you
lose a game you're focused on your
weaknesses sometimes you don't have the
time to recover you need you need a few
hours and you don't have that option in
blitz and rapid chess and
okay he's playing this out and
respect that he's down a whole rook
but um but up two minutes and he has a
night
he's up two minutes nights are tricky if
he somehow
uh can can grab one of the rooks with
his knight find some kind of tactic
maybe he could come back we've seen
crazier things than pogchamps
i like this move f5
i mean yeah let's do it open the king
knight g5 is an interesting move here
if only a little unusual but not bad
you could get this king on a forkable
square
right workable square
how to bait the king onto a forkable
square is is the question
um
because there's no reason for the black
king to come out here but he also has
that pass pawn on c4 maybe what he could
try do doing is bringing his king closer
king is a really important piece in the
end game and if he ends up having the
motor active king well give him chances
but at the same time black has so many
pieces he wants to get
he wants to be careful to not you know
get checks in the middle of the board or
leave the f and h pawn without a
defender so no correct strategy here but
desperado time for sure
h4 is a
a good idea but the problem after this
fork is that the only way to stay
protecting the f pawn is to put the king
on another forkable square d2 so this is
actually the right decision i think to
give up the f2 pawn and say see you
later try to activate the king like you
were saying alexandra
there's even these yeah maybe even
sacrifice h5 just to get a check onto f5
i was just gonna say that there's even
these crazy ideas that you sack this
pawn
you play night shack and you know even
if you get all of it you have nothing
but hey at least it looked cute along
the way right
so yeah at least you made your opponent
sweat a little bit maybe waste some time
hope he gets into time pressure and
blunders
the uh
you never know how how players will
handle time pressure and until you see
it right you know there's the
predictables we know how guys like
hikaru and magnus handle time pressure
really well yeah
how do you handle time pressure danny
not very well at all honestly not very
well at all yeah it's only getting worse
i shouldn't even be asked questions like
that anymore because it's
it's uh gamers
are used to having so much pressure on
them so i think they have a natural
inclination to be pretty good with it
but of course you still need some
experience yep
maybe maybe if croaky croakies play
something like rook h5 takes on h4 and
the king gets to g3 you know there's
some chances he can uh a win a piece off
of that there's still a couple traps so
we gotta give rubius all the respect for
continuing here yeah nobody and he's
still up two minutes on the clock and
croakies hasn't
hasn't like done anything special yet
right not taking you know
it's just that he's he's making a bunch
of me okay this is the first move to
convert that is that is indeed special
that's it chad i'm just gonna start
saying his name differently every time
and here we have croaker looking at the
board here we got the croakster
yeah
broketown
mr croakie
daryl can i call you daryl the gas man
the gas man just like make up nicknames
yep
chat coming up with some creative ones
too
what is croakies but is that a
wait is that his last name
uh his last name is croak
okay stephen the pawn was kind of
pinning my rick but
at least my rick was keeping their
knight under control though
yep that was a good point you got rid of
the pawn and
now that gives up a rook
yeah that's that's game if he sees it
or almost
but if he takes it
if he takes it then
maybe we can see some attacks like the
knight f5 move that we talked about yeah
oh he looks like and it looks like it's
hovering that's not okay come on rubies
that's not a good idea
i know i like what you're going for yeah
that laugh from rubius
i i hope he'll see the check first but
moving his work away is great too
oh yeah but no seeing the check first
could have been we could have had an
epic fog champs moment right there
harry mack looks a little different
today
harry max should take off the hat
sorry
i don't know why we're not here
[Music]
what was that
who was that not good words i i believe
uh
we have a checkmate in one that's been
on the board for several moves if if if
croaky sees rook a5 check
all right
well
he is giving the king some escape
squares here
oh man
chad
the the spanish speakers are really
laughing in here
i love it i love it
okay well rubius can still hope for a
stalemate here maybe he can put his king
in a position and then end up sacking
his rook
croaky 253 croakies has just too much
time here
yeah a little too much time to hope for
anything dramatic for for rubius um
all right king d4
not a ton of options here you just
okay king e5 nice he's putting pressure
on e6
all right well
rubios is going to keep this thing going
let's remind everybody our next match is
harry mack
taking on sapnap and harry just started
streaming over on his channel the
infamous freestyle rapper i think he is
infamous i think all rappers like being
called infamous even if they're not so
you're welcome harry infamous there you
go no he's he's awesome um
and yeah i was i was uh
joking about harry matt because i think
we had rubius's name as his earlier but
now we get to see who the real harry
mack is you know maybe a slim shady
reference going on there and wait a
second
rook takes h3 yeah that was a stalemate
oh no because that's exactly what he
needed to go for yeah oh my gosh
okay well congratulations
that could have been a a really funny
turnaround if rubios had spotted is
because if you play a move like this
everyone it's possible black takes it
just instinctively and then it's
stalemate obviously there would still be
checkmate but that was an opportunity
missed
um
[Music]
a last ditch attempts and if you've been
fighting for dear life that is the last
thing that you should at least try to
get in there but you know what rubius
was already in the mentality that he was
losing and it is tough to recover from
that croakies was the higher rated
player and he came and he performed
today but it wasn't as close as a 2-0
score would make seem
yeah agreed and if you missed if you
missed the uh the first game
you know that was really the uh
the opportunity the opportunity lost and
with that that's actually going to be
our eternal play of the game we're going
to go back to the first match
that these two played just a little bit
ago and bring up a position that that
actually had as i get to it had
everything going rubious way
he was on a roll
converting up a piece here even found
this brill we're sitting here i mean
chad is like what is going on with
ruby's we got a super grand master in
the building he's crushing it going to
win this pawn alexandra all looked good
until this moment right here where the
king took on f5 and we see the evil evil
bar reveal allowing that skewer
and just like that croakies comes back
to win this matchup versus rubio so
right there and it wasn't even over i
think if rubius had managed to get a
draw his mentality would have been so
much better that he would have had a
much better second game no you're right
he did have an opportunity later on a
good instructive lesson always keep the
king in front when you're trying to
block a corner pawn but it was that big
moment there that took a winning
position
to a losing one it was our eternal play
of the game let's remind everybody that
every single matchup is going to have an
eternal play of the game you can clip it
and ship it make make uh submit your own
potential moments for the play of the
games uh the ones that receive the most
votes will be turned into digital
collectible packs and dropped on
september 12th remember all the proceeds
are going to rad so if you've never kind
of played this game before
make a clip submit it like we said if it
becomes part of the collectible pack uh
it'll be available for fans to purchase
and all proceeds go toward the rad
charity three lucky winners who voted
will win one free pack which we will
announce live on september 12th you can
type the command eternal in chat for
more information
uh and uh yeah does that does that pack
right there i know i know it's a digital
pack but does that not look like you
open up that pack and like
i mean first of all there could be like
a protein drink i could open that just
squeeze that in my mouth that looks that
looks edible that is so aesthetically
pleasing wow i mean seriously i mean
yeah i know for sure i i love i love
what it looks like and uh i find the
idea of you know keeping these digital
moments online and rewarding fans for
finding the best moments giving back to
streamers really cool
well well i'm gonna contact eternal see
if there are any edible packs they could
send me because i'm gonna need a snack
at the break we're gonna be right
back them at home don't eat them at home
here don't eat them
i'm not endorsing eating the packs okay
we'll be right back all right good
keeping these digital moments online and
rewarding fans for finding the best
moments giving back to streamers really
cool
well well i'm going to contact eternal
see if there are any edible packs they
could send me because i'm going to need
a snack at the break we're going to be
right back
i'm at home don't eat them at home don't
eat them
wow the packs okay we'll be right back
all right good
guys i think i should refill my water
oh i just got
i just got the zoom link i just got the
zoom link okay let's see
here we go
[Music]
so
and we are back here pogchamps four
presented by coinboy coinbase corn base
no not corn based not a farm it's
coinbase anyway we have sapnaf and harry
mack here uh
guys we're excited for your match harry
how are you feeling about your first
ever chess match
well you know uh i'm i'm a bit nervous
but mostly i'm excited uh i'm brand new
to chess i've only been playing for a
few weeks so uh you know this is
somewhat insane for me to be here doing
this in front of so many people but uh
you know i'm i'm ready to have some fun
and and uh take it as it comes
wow that was so melodic
if anyone's watching the stream mute it
except for fans at home you guys keep it
on if anyone on camera is watching go
ahead and mute it um
go ahead alexandra
all right i think we're we're back harry
i mean even the way you said that
sounded super melodic i know you're
pretty new to chess and you have a
really positive attitude about it
already sapnap on the other hand has
been playing for a little bit longer he
is the more experienced player uh sapnap
what advice would you give harry going
into this match i'm gonna switch it up a
little bit here um just think your moves
out don't be dumb like i tend to be in
you know think about what you're doing
that's my best advice i can give you
much appreciated
sabnav you just played in in block
champs and
i heard you did pretty good what have
you done from block champs to now to get
to get ready for uh maybe a back-to-back
how many people win back-to-back events
on chess.com you might be one of the
first to do it if you have a good pog
champs
um
i have not prepared too much i played
some games before this um
but i'm gonna try and win because i feel
like if i can get past the group stage
then i'll just get better and better as
we go on
well sapnap you're really good at trash
talking your opponent um you are so
annoying to who you're playing it
reminded me of andrea who is your coach
so you know it makes sense and i say
that as a compliment but harry you know
you're also very quick-witted so i feel
like if this was open mic um it would
have been even closer yeah
yeah definitely i mean maybe i'll have
to freestyle while i play and and turn
it into sort of there will be a side
battle rap happening in addition to the
chess match
there you go
plea please do that that would be
amazing we we know that
sapnap is is trying to get his coach to
work a little more with him but i know
you've got you've got a coach in a grand
master but you can't spell chess without
okay i just said it robert has how's it
been going with robert he doesn't watch
these shows so now's your chance to talk
bad about him anything you want to say
right now
no you know what honestly i wouldn't
have a single bad thing to say about uh
grand master robert hess he's a a
wonderful teacher even better human
being and we had a few
very in-depth lessons so you know i
would say
i got just about as deep into the game
as i could possibly have hoped to get
considering the short span of time that
i've been playing here so big shout out
to robert he's the man well it's going
to be a fun couple weeks because
regardless of what happens today we've
got more chess matches ahead so we're
going to wish you both luck without that
we won't we won't bother you any further
say have fun getting into it we'll be
listening into your streams and maybe
we'll see on the other side
all right sounds good thank you guys
awesome good luck
all right another match-up about to get
underway let's remind everybody before
we move into our second set of games
that we are raising money for charity
just.com is matching a hundred thousand
dollars donated we've already had some
good ones come in let's uh let's try to
move that needle every day every little
bit counts everybody we're raising money
for rise above the disorder if you don't
know about this charity they are here to
help the tens of thousands of people
around the world who suffer from mental
health issues often the biggest problems
for people struggling with mental health
is affordability and accessibility and
they they work hard to make sure that
those things are not an issue use the
command rad in chat and click the donate
button below no matter where you're
watching you might even be watching on
chess.com tv there's a button right
there below the player if you're
watching on twitch there's a button
right there you can use the command
please continue to show your support and
uh we'll continue to bring you pogchamps
for coverage by presented by coinbase
we're going to be back in just a few
minutes
mental health is a serious topic and i'm
here to tell you that it's absolutely
okay to talk about it many people over
the course of their life will struggle
with something for me personally it's
always been different types of anxieties
and i know that i can be kind of prone
to bottling it all up i don't feel like
i want to bother those around me with it
so i just try to overcome it by myself
but i have found that it's better to
confide in my loved ones or my friends
or
in therapy but one of the major barriers
to therapy is the cost and so today we
are raising money for rise above the
disorder or rad for a hundred thousand
therapy sessions just a thirty dollar
donation will support therapy for one
week so do me a favor
reach out talk to somebody you're not
alone in this we're all going through
this together and we can overcome
audio through momentarily but then uh
there was a loop back
all right let me take a few deep breaths
so i can just focus on playing the best
i know how to play
thanks for all the love guys
wow
this is nuts y'all this is nuts
at least drop some beats nah man i can't
i gotta focus
thanks for being such a dude man no
doubt ash i got you
is it buffering
drop some chest bars yo we going into
the first round i don't even know how
it's about to go down hope i got my
maneuvers correct i'm about to hop in
the game and catch wreck chess y'all
know what's really gonna happen uh y'all
know we straight up snapping uh i'm
looking all up in discord wondering if
there's something i need to absorb
what's next i'm ready with the flex hmac
i'll be out of getting to the checks oh
hold on are we supposed to
jump back and zoom hold on
oh i'm not supposed to share this hold
on
yo yo
i can hear you
nice
do i
i can't hear any music
oh i do not need to join the zoom call
oh okay for sure hey i'm out man good
luck bro i'm excited to play
please you too
there's a lot going on my friends
wow y'all
it's going down down to down down diggy
down going down down to down down diggy
down yo bout to play chess about to play
chess three weeks strong about to leave
them all a mess sapnap we bout to put
you to sleep you gonna be taking the nap
when we finish my g
it's a lot of confidence for someone
who's only pl only played several games
to completion
i played a lot of games online and then
cats would leave and then i would win
because they left which like i felt like
i couldn't really own that
but um
you know
it is what it is
and we are back here for those of you
that have
like me been enjoying the freestyle
wrapped i mean
harry's wraps are so smooth
there aren't many people i'd like to go
to sleep to while they freestyle rap he
might be the
one that almost sounded like a diss
as if it would put you to sleep
um in a good way like it's
just smooth
yeah no he has a very relaxing voice um
there's sapnap it looks like he was
bobbing along to what harry mack was
saying actually and i know sapnap has
some of the craziest fans of any content
creator in terms of how much they they
support him so it's cool to see if
there's any sapnap fans in the chat
say hello let us know who you're rooting
for or if we got any hairy mac fans
we're a fan of them both and
harry mack is definitely the underdog he
is much more new than sapnap is
so let's be gentle on him in that regard
be gentle i don't even so sapp is not
streaming right now right
he's not okay he's not so
welcoming all sapnet fans who are here
and not on his stream and uh and all
harry mack fans this is this is
gonna be a matchup yeah i've obviously a
more experienced player in sapnap who
just played and won pogchamps right and
harry who brand new to the game
um
[Music]
he's kind of been brand new to chess but
he's been getting more and more involved
he did that freestyle video with some
some irena a few months ago that that
kind of went viral in the chess
community that was the first time i
actually had heard of harry mack and
since then i've watched a lot of his
freestyle raps
i see robert hess uh his grandmaster
coach and everybody's you know one of
their favorite grandmasters saying go
harry it's good to see him cheering for
his student here i hope robert just got
here and didn't hear all the bad things
harry just said about him a few moments
ago yeah that was really really
embarrassing um surprising for for that
to happen
so he's playing symmetrically here i
wonder if that's because he's not sure
what to do so if we see e6 then he's
definitely playing the copy sapnap
technique
although with a coach like robert robert
is going to do a very good job of being
balanced in terms of chef's principles
and
hey we also know that sapnap is a
student of andrea botez like all
students of andrea botes i'm glad your
sister's not listening she teaches them
the same opening the bad london she is
listening
with a delay
[Music]
yeah i know andre andre doesn't like
when when people
talk badly about the london so she'll
she'll be coming for you danny just be
careful because she's been talking about
body slamming everyone lately she's just
provoking a lot of fights so i'm glad
you do a lot of crossfit yeah
there's the heads up i saw
here he was wearing like a cucumber suit
or something or like a pickle suit what
was the deal with that oh yeah oh i was
actually the one in the pickle soup but
let's move on from that so yeah let's
move on samnap is playing a version of
the london we know because he's done
coaching with andrea he has a really
nice solid setup here and he's already
doubled one of harry mack's pawns but at
the same time the pawn on f5 if he makes
the move like g6 and maybe fianchetto's
bishop it's a pawn that is doubled but
protected and controlling the center so
it's one of those borderline areas where
it's like is it a weakness is it a
strength it'll be both in different
times
no and this will be a good one that we
know rob robert will build on this is
also a good move to make this trade i
hope i hope if it happens he recaptures
with the queen because
this is the kind of position that can be
very hard for london players to face
because
it gets such a big stranglehold over the
e4 square it's hard
to
to get around that in the center so i
really like this move
we'll see how sapnap approaches it
um yeah and this is tricky for sapnap
because he has to decide whether he's
okay with doubling his own pawns bishop
g3 is a movie often seen to london
because if the bishops get traded off
you open up the h file you have a nice
king side attack he moves the bishop
away um and he goes to pin the knight
instead on f6 which i think is
always
a tricky thing for newer players to deal
with these pins can get really annoying
even just the pressure of having it i
agree but i but i do like that harry got
castled quickly like no no hesitation
right boom he just castled
and wow now we see sapnap is getting
super aggressive in the center as we're
going to listen into harry mack here
let's see how he handles his pawn on e4
um
okay yup you can take it he's not sure
his instinct is correct here let's see
if he falls through there he goes he did
it nice harry
i mean again sapnap is the more
experienced player and sapnap when he's
focused can play extremely well yeah it
seems like he may have just gotten a
little bit overeager as he pushed the
pawn there
and uh harry harry's focus as well not
even rapping
no music just totally in it and we have
the same chair harry mack and i actually
okay what am i gonna get these
cheers are super comfortable
yeah i'll do my best danny you deserve
it you're always putting in the hours
here no i i'm also not kidding they're
very comfortable and if you're sitting
on it a lot it's important to have a
good chair yeah it's time it's time
wow
harry with the rook e8 bringing the rook
to an open file preparing a discovery
check
robert are you sure harry is new to
chess or is there some uh you know
colluding going on between the coach and
the student here because are we sure
robert is not sitting on the other side
of harry if harry goes on to have a
great pog chance performance i'm also
gonna because we
and i don't want to say anything bigger
but i'll say this we're doing we're
doing some awesome stuff with harry mack
outside of pogchamps which is coming
later this year so we when we first
reached out to him and his team
what spoiler
yeah continue sorry he said he said he
was willing to play pogchamps but he was
super nervous because he hadn't played
chess so the fact that he had robert in
his corner was a big reason why he was
willing to but if he goes on to win
pogchamps i'm gonna call bs on that
little little you know
kind of
whatever sandbagging
um
okay here we go ooh
so h6
um
sapnap
i like i like taking the knight on f6
and pushing e5
oh that is a problem because his bishop
on g5 is hanging and he looks like he is
attacking two pieces at the same time
the bishop and the knight but he cannot
take it because of what danny just
pointed with the arrows there the rook
on e8 the king is in the center and the
pawn cannot move
so if harry max sees it and takes the
bishop that's huge for him
yeah this is a big moment
i wonder if harry will realize that the
pawn on e5 is pinned because the sapnap
also didn't see it or he wouldn't have
pushed it so this is a tricky moment
let's listen and see what harry's
thinking yeah
and also speaking of checking on
streamers we have our favorite irish lad
in the chat saying does anyone know how
to check mate well it seems like from
your last game you certainly did
shout out to you uh mr croakster
uh
got to do something
is he going to take the pawn what's
funny is even though he doesn't have to
do this what he just did alexandra it's
actually not a bad idea right to open up
the center with the with the white king
sitting there regardless of
of the fact that he that the bishop on
g5 is saying this is actually a good
move because now if he takes with his
rook he's go no no no not with a bishop
with the rook
i mean he's still honestly pretty well
but if he takes with the rook he's gonna
check the king and attack the bishop yep
okay uh again i i think this is heading
in a way that probably sapnap is going
to kind of get crazy i've ever done with
one
uh okay he plays the right move
here but again he's so new that i'm just
completely impressed with how well he's
playing agreed agreed big brain
we like big brains and we cannot lie
you other rappers can't deny
when harry harry walks in
yeah we need his help here danny with a
house by his side
you might and um
mm-hmm
get stunned stunned
whoa harry if you need some backup
rappers right here me and alexandra we
clearly have the skills to pay the bills
um yeah we we have the skills to make
him look 10x better by comparison and uh
you know sometimes you surround yourself
by lesser talent to feel better not that
he needs that as one of the best
freestyle rappers out there
but knight f3 sapnap i like what he's
doing here he's preparing a castle i
just hope he's careful because if harry
moves his bishop because he sees it's
under attack then he's going to be
attacking the bishop on e3 so tricky
position
yeah if
if the knight
poked the bishop just enough to move it
so harry brings the queen to a very good
square
again this is a great developing move
it's not the best move obviously we know
to take advantage of the king on the e
file but the truth is the really good
really good solid move like you said for
someone who's just learning the game and
he might have an attack if if sapnap
castle will say okay he does i wonder if
harry will find a move like knight g4
to bring all the pieces over here to the
king side and attack
sapnap is pondering he he doesn't look
stressed yet which is good um but then
again he hasn't showed a lot of emotion
i like it he's maintaining his poker
face here
harry is hovering to move the knight to
e4
which is instinctually nice because he
wants to put his knight towards the
center he already changed his mind but
he doesn't want to trade off the pieces
necessarily since he has such good
attacking chances but again given that
he's been playing for you know just a a
few lessons this is yeah hot minute
and
he plays b6 again not a bad move it's
just a supportive move he might play c5
next i think he's kind of taking the let
me be solid here approach and see what
happens next
your opponent will sometimes blunder if
they don't have a plan right often
people make mistakes in bad positions
but the other place they make mistakes
is if they don't know what to do
though it's not the worst approach
sometimes to make a make a supportive
move that improves your position a
little bit and and make your opponent
prove that they have a plan
right
and i think we if we go back to the
screen with both cams no sapnap does
look like he is having a bit of a tough
time here um
but now he's finally starting to get
some counter play he has
actually a
pretty good position now relative to
where it could have gone and he takes on
a7 which looks like it was potentially a
poison pawn but there's no rook a8 right
away yeah it's it's hard to know why
this move is bad for
players of this level the truth is the
best idea for harry still would be to
look at the the opportunity for all
these pieces to work together and attack
over here a move like knight g4 would be
amazing uh but it's hard to see
sometimes the forest through the trees
you don't even realize how maybe weak
this pawn is the bishop is loose and
undefended hard to see those things with
the pieces right in front of you
yeah absolutely um
i mean
harry hasn't blundered anything yet
which is
actually not a roast it is so hard to
not blunder your pieces when you're
getting started i mean he's you know 280
because he's learned in the last two
weeks or so and he hasn't blundered a
single piece and now he's attacking uh
then i don't have three and he's going
to trade it off but if sapnap wouldn't
have uh taken the bishop he could have
had the h2 pawn there so he has some
chances he sapnap also rocking the very
very large mug
um alex
when are you gonna get
an overly large grotesque looking mug
like
um
you know
that is a good question danny uh i i do
like
getting up more often stretching the
legs a little bit so i keep the cups
small so that i make sure to get some
exercise in it's true those ch those
those bugs don't scream healthy
lifestyle you're right they don't scream
healthy lifestyle like how much are you
going to put in that because no matter
what kind of liquid you're getting
you're getting your water it's great but
if it's water
if yeah maybe not but less great is i
was just complimenting harry and he
totally deserves it but he did end up
losing a piece here so sapnap is now up
a piece and up two minutes on the clock
computer really doesn't like queen b7
the reason is this move c5 which would
actually both did you just find it
not yet no that was you danny
sometimes i make moves and i don't know
if i did or
that was hilarious not yet danny that
was you okay
no no but uh danny i'm i'm glad you
found it that's important you've been
doing your tactics thank you oh no and
here he just
dropped a rook
he blocked the queen from protecting yep
what's the rook the snap sees the
tactics
that's gonna leave a mark
oh that's rough um but again
still
if he's performing at this level within
a few weeks
he's
gonna have some serious chances to to
win
uh even if he ends up let's say in the
consolation bracket but hey he might
even make the championship bracket as a
new chess player with his rate of
learning no totally i mean
he could still make the championship
bracket but even if he doesn't it's
amazing when you see i think players
start out in the beginning of pogchamps
and at the end of the two weeks
you know and it'll be really important
that he builds on this game even if he
loses to to realize that hey like you
were off to a great start you were
actually maybe even winning out of the
opening focusing on the positive and uh
i think sometimes for beginner players
if they don't have the right coach it
can all they do is focus on the loss but
we know that robert is the kind of
person who's going to be like hey man
there's a lot to build on here and uh
and focus on where he was actually
better and maybe winning out of the
opening
man robert is the coach that everybody's
ever dreamed to have you know
i know i can i can confirm that he's a
hot commodity a lot of people want to
get coaching lessons with him and he
doesn't return their phone calls for
years
okay danny i i can tell you're targeted
there i'm sorry you had to go through
that man um but staff now playing very
well uh queen f8 looks like a very scary
move he can go for the checkmate i like
queen b7 as well he's attacking the e4
pawn um
even though he's up a rook
he still has to finish it off here so
let's give him some some credit for his
nice comeback from a kind of shaky
opening position yeah
agreed agreed agreed
and uh
okay after queen eight i think sapnap
will we'll see what he does here does he
take with the rook or does he take with
the queen i think the queen would be a
really good sign for him to say okay
also a good pun i think that one of the
things that players want to build on if
you're if you're winning and the better
player is look for ways
that you could have simplified and one
faster like don't tell yourself just
like you don't want to tell yourself a
negative story if you lose focus on what
the positive things are you can control
if you win don't tell yourself you
played like gary caspar of the whole
game right look for ways that you could
have won faster and often an area of of
of improvement for for people getting
better is to look where they could have
traded they could have eliminated pieces
and so queen takes e4 getting the queens
off the board a good thing for sapnap to
look for in the future but he's still
obviously in a really good position here
so yeah definitely sorry i slipped into
coach mode there i know i blacked out a
little bit i'm back i'll be i'll make
awkward jokes coach mo coach mode is
great um i really hope that there's
people watching this who are new to
chess and i think
that is what i like the best about pog
champs we went from watching these
really high level games and feeling like
only people who have spent decades on
chess can enjoy it too whoa harry mack's
been playing chess for three weeks um he
can already play at this level he's
gonna improve quickly and i hope he's
gonna have fun too yep
and uh coaching is needed to have fun
because it is hard to lose i like queen
c6 he's he's pinning the rook and in
some ways actually preparing to simplify
if harry moves the rook because then he
can just trade queens
oh that's a free pawn
but i like that he was aware that moving
it protected e4 if that was harry's idea
obviously if sap nap sees this i keep
wanting to call him sap maybe he doesn't
like that nickname like
like sap uh for everybody seeing team
sapnap in the chat
what do you think you guys always call
him snap nap or does he have any
nicknames that like saptown like hey
what's up what's up what's up
what's up like the app saponin instead
of
what's happening just happening like
what are you doing just happening he
should have his own segment called
what's happening what's happening sap
napping what's that no it's hard it's
too hard to say
we keep trying to do the smooth word
place i think we're both inspired by
harry and it's been a little bit tough
we'll we'll ask harry to make a rap
about sapp at some point
this uh particular people are saying
this is not sponsored by snapple
it's but but i might want to sample
some some some sam okay
all right there we go sap has taken care
of business here the brooks have
activated
the only crazy things that we could see
in a position like this might be some
sort of weird
weird blunder or uh
or um
[Music]
a stalemate but sap looks like he's
playing very well
he wasn't too i mean we can reveal that
you know in the call see if he's gonna
see the rook here yeah he saw it he does
yep
in the call before we were live he he
was saying that he was nervous even
though he's done some training
uh he was playing george he said
yeah he was playing against george not
found apparently they were training um a
little bit and i know they play chess
together pretty often and george is
a very good chess player uh sapnap was
saying how george tends to win when
they're when they're goofing off but he
is getting closer to george's level when
they're serious and he did beat george
in uh the block champs tournament we
hosted so
it's always the most fun when you're
training with your friends so it's
awesome that he has that support
okay queen takes e8 zap will probably
take back but he does he did have check
made on g7 but this is the
most logical way to victory here
and robert hess harry max coach he's
doing so well proud of him especially
after how new he is to chess robert you
are too wholesome for this world but i
agree with you he's doing a great job he
is and i'll be curious what he does with
white i mean he'll have a little more of
the initiative
um it'll be fun to see game two here
coming up um and again this isn't over
yet
there's always stalemate possibilities
stranger things have happened on
pogchamps
for sure and i'd be impressed if sapnap
uh you know saw saw the checkmate here
he didn't quite he played he takes
it but now he doesn't now see rook f8
yep
that's also a checkmate you know
checkmate in three is still wo results
at the end of the day checkmate now with
the rook
and indeed
zapnap finds it
there you go congratulations he pulled
it off he's playing well despite being
trapped and whatever white
wow guys
wow
that was insane
he did well
harry he's got another game coming up um
we are we're probably going to tune into
him at the break maybe he'll check out
his uh his game report get some advice
from coach coach hess
and uh alexander and i will be right
back
not bad for a rook they said
great job though man y'all are so
supportive
oh they said it was a great game for my
rating i'll take it
i'll take it
i can't look at chat while i'm playing
so
now is my time to build with y'all
what's sandbagging
yeah what was the commentary man what's
being said or is that illegal i don't
even know
somebody stop me now
let me ask
i just asked if i can engage with chat
during the break
oh they said yeah of course okay cool
cool
how'd it look out there man
sandbagging is going easy
they said i was going easy no i was
trying my hardest
no they said during breaks all is normal
wow all right yeah
yo this here is the break in that last
game i made a lot of mistakes got messed
up as we move towards the finish a lot
of my big pieces straight got diminished
was hoping i could win this but didn't
have the skills i'm still blessed for
this opportunity to build and honestly
just playing these games gives me a
thrill pog champs represent y'all know
this is ill i'm back up on it and
i'm rhyming off the chat press play i
make roman tickle yell hey i'm on my
break right now getting what i deserve i
just started learning so we moving with
the curve yeah i do my thing and y'all
know that i'm about to bless i hope my
learning can curve towards success yeah
that's what we all about you know i'm
representing and people love the ill
vibes mac is inventing uh and y'all know
that i be feeling blessed it makes sense
cause robert hess rhymes with chess yeah
it has to rhyme imma lift you higher
when i'm all up on the stream and y'all
know i'm spitting fire look at the
analysis of your game so you can
understand the moves that truly were
ashamed
i'm on my pure route trying to get the
nerves out we be all here part champs
flowing free got you yelling now omg got
the type of bars that be blowing up the
cypher circle mac b winning the games
plural um i was doing really well for a
new chess dude and making a lot of moves
oh that's tight glad they compare me to
the beast cause when i'm out there
making moves i'm yelling out she's king
me homie but we ain't playing checkers
y'all know i grip up on the mic and then
i wreck you winning in the battle from
here to seattle trying to defend my king
with the castle go harry my flow's scary
when i get down people loving the way my
life spit sounds what is harry max chess
skill rating very low 276 but still i'm
awesome heavenly every time that i
spit forever we lit and y'all know that
my rhymes are legit amazing every time
i'm lyrically blazing i'll be the one
that everyone in the game is paige and
wtf he's blessed he's doing his thing in
the competition piece to everyone
pinging yeah party parrot party parry
with the dance moves when it comes to
bars i'd be doing what they can't do i
just realized y'all can't see the chat
my bad
[Music]
can we just stay on break forever harry
back is so good danny oh we're back
harry mack first of all that was
ridiculous that was ridiculous
the
the endorsement to like analyze your
chest get better working in hess into
the chat i don't even i don't i honestly
don't even know what happened but it was
amazing
um and what he does also is he gets
words from his chat he's done things
like that where you know chad will give
him a ton of words and he just instantly
incorporates them it is just phenomenal
to watch
and he's adding chat right now
so you know what we gonna do let me
switch it back to chess and continue to
make moves let's go
yeah wow
uh out to mayfield who just donated 500
bucks we just we just crossed over 600
on the day let's go
raising money for brad rise above the
disorder
and uh i hope that you guys will use the
command shout out to him
dude shout out
yeah he's an og he's been supporting
chess streamers since when there were
you know very few of them uh so thank
you so much april we really appreciate
it
yeah he's uh been around for uh
for a very long time in the chess
community that's awesome thank you so
much
and i think we're going to get set for
our second game i don't even want to
play i just want to listen to harry mack
rap about chess that's all i want to do
if he busts
if he busts into anything else we'll
just shut up and we'll just let him
we'll just let him go
yeah we'll just go and we'll we'll
listen into whatever he's saying
okay so he's starting off with e4 yeah i
like it i'm curious what robert taught
him here but i guess we'll figure it out
very soon yep
exactly
teach new players do you usually go for
openings or principles when you're
teaching them how to play e4 especially
at this level
it's so hard because you don't have time
is limited okay but
now he's got an opportunity
um
bishop c4 is a great move
so we need to give sapnap the note to
not push the pawn on f6 because it does
weaken his king side
i think it's he's trying to play
something like a london with the black
side of the pieces so that's probably
why he pushed it
but it does not work uh in the e4 line
and now his bishop is also blocking his
own pawns here so it is a bit of a
cramped position but still
well i think i think we're here to take
advantage of sorry go ahead no i was
going to say to answer your question on
openings or principles i think we can
see robert
probably emphasized a lot of like hey if
you start every game with get your
pieces out a couple pawns in the center
and get castled you're not going to lose
quickly which is true so i think already
harry is going to be on the right foot
regardless of the strength of his
opponent so i think it's probably clear
that robert focused on that type of
thing and then once that once your
students doing that it's easier to get
more specific and say hey next time you
have this opportunity before you castle
if your opponent weakens your life
squares look to open the center and take
advantage of it um so i would say
principles first opening second is
usually the right thing to do
that is the danny teaching way and
you're always so principled so
chat take note
knight to
c3 that is something that he probably
learned as a principal you're trying to
get your knights out you get the knights
before the bishops and here he is
doubling his pawns but he's taking
towards the center so that is another
nice perk for him and he's defending the
pawn on d4 so that he could recapture
and have a nice reinforcement in the
center yep
so now now that you've gotten developed
and you control the center
this is where you know it gets tricky
and
if your opponent's king is still in the
center the most the most often thing you
should look for is is there any forcing
way for me to open and take advantage of
it if not then keep playing moves like
rookie one maybe get the bishop out
but okay d5 is also not a bad movie he
attacks the knight and he's gonna look
for
maybe moving the bishop on the next move
we'll see
um
repcamo9 just donated a hundred dollars
i think we're getting to at least a
thousand dollars on this first day maybe
more thank you so much everybody
that is awesome thank you
um sapnap attacking his bishop here so
this is going to be harry's first
critical move he has to see it and
either defend the bishop or move it away
and we do notice that sapnap's king is
still in the center of the board he's
behind development so if he could do
anything to keep him there
then that should be a correct intuition
even though bishop e5 check allows
bishop d7 okay he saw the bishop he
protected it that's great
great move
yep
yeah i see christy hellyes sing team
sapnap um christy it's nice for you to
come in here and support your favorite
creators for all of you who came in here
to see how they play chess shout out to
you guys woodstock 37 get em harry you
guys are awesome a really nice to see
positivity in the chat especially for
players who are out there trying
something new and giving their best
97 a good move from sap nav now he's
going to get castle but look at harry he
just continues to follow all the right
principles bring pieces into the center
this is this is both a good move in the
sense that i like that sapnap is
thinking about how to attack the center
but it's also a very risky move if harry
sees an opportunity to take and open the
bishop this is kind of a big moment here
we'll see what harry does with the pawn
whether he takes it or not
yeah um he pushes h3 instead so i feel
like he's remembering a lot of things
robert told him and h3 is often a
strategic move it's hard to know when to
do what and when to react but again he
just certainly has a natural gift for
chess with how he's seen the most
important threats
agreed yeah no he's
again this is the guy who was learning
how the pieces moved a few weeks ago
no that's that's insane
i don't know how good harry he learned
so quickly yeah and sapnap captures
towards the center which is another
principle that we know he learned oh and
harry mack takes with the pawn um
if he would have taken with a bishop he
would have been
keeping sapnap from castling
so now snapnap is playing this very well
yeah and the trade on c4 i think harry
will take back because he
he saw that idea when he brought the
queen up so i think he'll take and he's
he's got a good position now the main
piece left that hasn't been playing
that's the one he needs to see and if he
if he sees an idea of maybe bringing it
to a3
there's a weak pawn on d6 but developing
it anywhere would be would be a good
next step
yeah absolutely finishing the
development process
and sapnap on his end he's just going to
be happy to castle and then the pawn on
d5 might actually become a target for
his in the future bishop f5 i like a lot
as well because he's attacking c2 and
he's creating space on c8 to bring his
rook
yeah this is a great move and seriously
we're talking a lot about harry just
learning the game zapnap he just came
off a huge win block champs two right
that's uh one notch in his belt he might
get a second belt oh i forgot to say we
actually have
hog champ's four belts by the way
i've got them to you really yeah this
this year we have this this time we
actually have two we have a we have a
pog champs built for both the winner of
the championship bracket
and the constellation bracket so two
belts
okay that is that is pretty cool you
know
uh
yeah i can't tell if it's dorky or cool
but i'm leaning towards the ladder chat
chad is getting really excited so i
think it's the latter people are pogging
i i mean
who came up with the name pog champs
actually
well it was based on the the
whatever the the poggers kind of right
thing right
which
apparently pog means play of the game
did you know that okay it makes sense no
i didn't know that
i didn't think i didn't know that either
until recently but apparently pog means
play the game and so people would say
poggers like play of the game and that
became like a thing
um
sapnap grabs and free pawn he actually
saw that it was a target attacked with
his queen and his knight and he gobbled
it right up
yeah apparently pog rolls off the tongue
better than pot potka vodka oh wait
apparently it's not how it started
oh so i just made up that whole thing
uh or maybe i i don't know don't listen
to chat ignore ignore chat
you've already been debated once today
alexandra
uh no i you guys i didn't know this i
already said i didn't know but i'm just
getting debated i don't even know if
danny's story is true i don't know what
to believe anymore you tell me chat
where did pog originate yeah
danny's making stuff now people are
saying it's irish
oh man apparently croakies invented the
term pod champs um that's that's the
official thing
there you go
we solved the mystery here
all right uh knight takes d5 is played
harry is on the clock
a move a move that would be amazing to
see would be the move c4 to attack the
knight
and attack the queen here um
a hard move to see but it is an
attacking move and so some he just
played it harry mack just played c4
beautiful move sapnap's queen and his
knight both under attack this is a
honestly tricky play for him to to come
and save here the only reason it's not
winning is because of one move you have
to see queen a6 which would would move
the queen to safety insane yeah and pin
the pawn because of the rook so that's
like
see c4 is basically a winning move
because queen a6 would be so hard for
sapnap to find he finds this move then
double poggers double the fun not
sponsored by doublemint gum double the
poggers
oh man well sapnap is up on time here so
he does have
oh i mean it was too hard of a move to
see i i do not blame him uh but if if
harry max sees it we got a brother's
gambit danny andrea has been producing
him i don't know what to say oh yeah
yeah yeah does he see it it could be a
could be a problem
uh-oh
does he don't know if he sees it
no we're botes gambiting all over the a5
square
oh no even taking the knight is better
because then at least he gets a free
piece
you gonna do it
sapnap also just had a reaction sapnap
just saw he's shaking his head oh he
shook his head he knows he got super
lucky oh my gosh happy look at sapnav
you guys he's just relieved
oh there you go okay why is my face on
that queen
that's what's going on there um
okay queen to b6 now harry harry still
has a chance to take the knight
but sapnap i mean he knows he just got
away with murder there before harry even
played rookie one he was shaking his
head
uh-oh
oh man
okay well sapnap saved it good on him
for finding the move
again harry's been playing for three
weeks
so it was not the thing is you see a
move it's attacking one of your pieces
and your initial reaction is to defend
the piece rather than to see what you're
attacking as you start to develop over
time you're looking at both but super
super normal for him and
hey he still has chances to recover here
even though he is now down on exchange
but that's not the end of the world no
you're totally right and robert and i
talked about this many times especially
with new players and during the last pog
chances because a new player
doesn't have confidence that comes with
experience and that sounds like okay
well thanks captain obvious but it's
really true it means that every time
there's a move played their initial
instinct for a very long time is that
they're missing something right to be
defensive
and it takes a while before a player can
can look at someone's moves and say like
actually like they don't know what
they're doing here right and that's what
allows you to punish your opponent for
mistakes so totally totally natural to
be more defensive minded when you're
first learning the game
well speaking of defensive minded sapnap
doesn't seem to care at all that is king
is in the center of the board he is not
concerned he has put off his castle and
he's just pushing his center pawns here
and even now he plays the move queen of
fight he's not worried about it no no
king in the center no problem
he's just too confident here which is
fair because you know even a draw wins
for him here he won the first game he's
high rated still has to be careful
though because when you do get too
confident and you lose focus that's when
the slip ups could happen yep
well
the
the game again started out on a great
foot for harry mack i'm super impressed
i can't wait to see where this goes for
the next couple weeks for him and all
the freestyle rapping will be treated
too if you have not gone to harrymac
official on twitch and hit the follow
button what is wrong with you did you
see him freestyle rapping about game
analysis
i mean
yes seriously agreed twitch.tv slash
harry mack official check him out now he
is super talented he's out here trying
something new and when you see true
talent it's nice to support it because
it is hard to make a chat because it's
not something we get on chess shows very
often what i'm hosting true yeah i mean
look at us that's why we're here right
oh self-deprecating humor for the win
dan i haven't been doing that for years
um
yeah you put you put the two of us it's
just like a spiral in but okay sapnap
finally castled this is good to see
um just out of principle because he's
putting his king to safety and he's also
activating the rook on f8 so it does two
things at the same time
and uh great move here f4 yep he's
putting pressure on d6 he has to be a
little bit careful with that queen
eyeing the rook on e2 if his rook were
to move away
bishop f4 guys the bishop isn't hanging
some people are saying the bishop is
hanging on f5 it is defended by the
queen
yeah queen defends the bishop here
and i really like this move from harry
bishop to f4 now
again
putting several moves together that
attack the same spot on a chessboard
again like
it depending on your level of chess as a
viewer you're like okay i know that but
no it really is an important step as far
as someone's growth is because that's
the basic part of a plan is is two
pieces attacking one spot
and
that's that's what you want to start to
see is is regardless of the target is
let's play one move and then bring
another but this move
okay this is super risky it might even
force harry to find a great idea which
would be to take twice
and then boom town now who's winning
that is g5
also the crazier thing is if you would
oh he didn't take it okay never mind oh
man would have loved to see that but
again sacrificing your bishop for two
pawns and getting an attack like that
it's gonna be easier for him to see an
even trade like the night for the bishop
which he did go for but this was such a
beautiful counter play to find and
maybe even
had on it real quick again
and it'll be for sap as he continues to
also get better he could win the whole
thing right he just came up block champs
these are the kind of moves you want to
avoid when you're winning any move
around your king side is just
unnecessary um and again what's the
thing you want to what you want to learn
to do when you're winning how could i
have traded faster how could i have
eliminated my opponent's chances it's a
very risky move even though harry didn't
find it so it'd be a good thing for him
to learn from after the game too i'm
sure he'll look at it
yeah definitely but now he's going to
have to try to survive down a rook yep
he is keeping his cool what advice would
you give him he's down a rook trying to
survive what do you do
um bust into freestyle rap
just make it entertaining if you're like
what i do every time i'm losing
um
you just you just bust out the wrap
fairy did you know that i did that yeah
that's my thing like hey no i did i
learned it i learned it uh during this
stream it's very very surprised danny
um
okay he's gotta take that oh he played
actually that's not a bad move king to
g3 king to g2 if you can take back here
with the rook
there's still an outside chance that
white's pieces
quickly almost accidentally go toward
the black king because sapp needs to
coordinate against the white king before
before harry does so
yep okay
at least gonna give him some chances
did he just
so this is
wait
he just played e3 attacking the rook yes
there's the queen there's a queen under
attack if harry met
oh my god why
oh uh
that was okay okay double bow test
gambit
oh my gosh oh man and then sap takes
here it saves the queen because the rook
is pinned there was
oh my god if harry saw queen bee three
right now that would be dope
he's not gonna see it uh
yeah queen v3 you know win a rook back
he has chances
but
that was that was that was man
it
it goes back to what to what what we
said when it when you're first learning
the game someone makes an attacking move
you're always looking at the immediate
defensive option
and you're just not always looking
for your chances
yep
again we're not throwing hairy shade
here not at all it is
it was just a very important moment that
if he would have somehow seen it would
have changed the entire course of the
game
now he's got his king two pawns and a
queen and sapnap is vicious he moves his
rook over to c8 he's preparing rook c3
to win his queen and harry just pushes
his pawn because at the end when you're
just losing you don't really know what
to do other than push puns
no totally and harry harry is going to
look at these games with rob and be like
oh man like i'm doing good like that's
seriously what he should be thinking
because he's going to look at this and
be like i had major chances
to win actually not even like to hold
but to win both these games and that's
that's the thing you focus on because
um
you know you're you're often just not
realizing your chances as you're first
learning the game and he was he was
doing very good and now now there's a
checkmate
okay maybe harry sees a chance to
stalemate himself if he advances the
pawn there's a stalemate idea
ah
yeah but he might also bait sapnap into
taking the pawn
come on try harry push the pawn change
up the pawn
oh
there's a there's a chance here that
something goes terribly wrong for sapnap
after the king moves he needs to see
this
he would still win the match even if it
was cellmate but i think he would be in
a little bit of pain so he did check
mate he finished it off
nicely done for stop now
damn there you go man
wow
epic
harry did great
and he's obviously he really did yeah
sapnap let out a sigh of relief like
that wasn't an easy game for him yeah
and and the probably the the moment that
had him most on the edge of his seat is
going to be our eternal play of the game
uh we're going to go back to the
position where
he actually
in one moment
could have lost could have lost the
queen right and we're gonna be looking
for every opportunity
to uh to point out a bowtie's gambit but
this was really to play the game because
i think it shows two things one the fact
that sapnap saw it alexandra after this
move shows it's very good on him right
even if you make mistakes sing it
afterwards that's a huge step so so he
gets credit for it but also it'll be the
probably the most important step for
harry to realize in some of these games
he's playing
that he's doing well this was a very
good move a double attack in fact that
could have gone a direction for him to
win if he had seen this idea of bishop
takes a5
but ultimately he got away from him and
that was our eternal play of the game
real quick use eternal so apparently all
you got to do i learned this at the
break all you have to do is to sign up
at eternal it's free and then once your
twitch account is connected you just
type the word eternal if you agree that
it was the play of the game or just
submit it to
the the compilation of the packs that
they're putting together the best
moments are going to be put into a
collectible pack that will be dropping
on three lucky people for free on
september 12th and anyone who chooses to
purchase that pack of collectibles we'll
have that money go directly toward our
charity
that is rad rise above the disorder so
anyway again there's all those packs
there they look really delicious i'm not
endorsing that you eat digital things
um
but it again very
very they're making them look
attractive like i want to own those i
don't know why i want to own those
things
they're collecting yeah i'm
i'm i'm really impressed with what
eternal is doing so far uh and i just as
i said love the branding on what they
got going on
all right everybody we're gonna be right
back enjoy the smooth sounds of harry
mack that's what i'm gonna be doing i'm
not gonna do anything but sit here and
listen to harry mack at the break when
we return it'll be our third matchup of
the day pogchamps four presented by
coinbase returns in a few
um
so yeah i've been grinding it as much as
possible i mean i've uh
you know bearing my uh
my my current schedule but
um
i played as much as possible between
like three weeks ago and and and now
but uh yeah shout out to uh to robert
hess because uh without him i wouldn't
have even looked it wouldn't have looked
as promising
uh
in the beginning stages of the game i
had some solid concepts
uh and some principles
that uh i was hoping i'd be able to rely
on uh in in the heat of battle and and i
think actually yeah you know in terms of
like the beginning of the game seemed
decent from my perspective but um yeah
but now it's just about uh
yeah oh i'm on chess's stream again
freestyle
can i freestyle for the for chess.com
yeah
yeah we on chats.com h mac improvising a
song yeah and you know that i'm blessed
though i just got whooped at chess all
good man i'm about to learn the game
hmac coming off the top with the flames
we're gonna make it happen when i'm on
the scene i'm the most powerful real
just like queen yeah hmac i'll be making
moves every time i'm on a man i'm
certain to improve yeah you know that
i'm winning in the battle got to protect
the king up in the castle hmag there
ain't nothing they could tell us all the
strong moves is getting developed hmac
got the bars they remember i'll burn you
into ambers i'm controlling the center
yeah and y'all know that i speak through
flows i started playing three weeks ago
uh hoping i could somehow be a winner
but the truth is man i'm only a beginner
hmac when i'm done with them like i slam
it uh trying to beat y'all dead with
queen's gambit coming up the top of the
dome hmac y'all know i'm a lock in the
zone uh every time i spit i'd be great
in this game though i got beat with the
checkmate yeah y'all know i'm trying to
hold it down uh honestly i got played
for the clown h-mac i come off the top
kicking mad facts by the way big shout
out goes to snap nap yeah hmac ima break
it down every time i rhyme imma make the
sails coming up the tip of this my
lyrics are ridiculous and when they come
to bars i'm low pro and conspicuous huh
and they know what i'm about age mac
i'll be staying on my route uh and y'all
know i finesse for people while i'm
making big moves on the chessboard
hoping i can truly make it happen i'm
locked in y'all know if the ship i'll be
the captain h man gotta be the number
one emcee coming with the bars that's
the people about to envy uh i'll be out
here living on my purpose when i was
playing chess homie i was getting
nervous yeah and y'all know that i'm
rising out the shoe we're playing in
front of thousands of viewers hmac man
i'm crowded rousing i'm down to rap in
front of fifteen thousand but playing
chess man i was getting worse hey drag
when i rhyme i'm gonna go berserk yeah
but then again yo i'm eight grade cause
that's some of the best chess i ever
played so i guess you could say that i
rose to the occasion even if the end
result wasn't amazing blazing imma break
it down here in rap form every time that
i rhyme i'm a rap form everybody lining
up all around the corner just to hear
the number one performer when they come
to lyrics i focus like a brainiac and
when they come to bars they'll be
calling me and maybe i can only bear my
soul i can feel the burn and i practice
every day y'all can see me learning h
mad man you know i'm about to scorch
this when i'm flown when i'm growing
just like a rainforest shouts at the
access to throwing me the bits every
time that i'm rhyming i'll be flowing
through the jet got the game up a
checkmate they can make moves i know i'm
a king in the game for the grove hmac
called upon it imma break it down coming
off the top of this with the crazy sound
microphone i'm controlling that and when
i'm rhyming i got them yelling holy crap
it's hairy mac i'ma break it with the
lyrical fix and everybody wanna see me
live stream on twitch i'm about to make
it happen it's time to direct you i'm
advanced homie we've been playing chess
not checkers all these other rappers in
the game getting mad at me i gotta think
ahead you know i gotta have the strategy
on how these are god creations they be
saying that he got the best
improvisation that i ever heard how
could rappers manage i got the advantage
i'm about to slam it when they come to
lyrics they be knowing that them clever
could the rapper be me coming off the
top of saying never when it comes to
freestyles everybody can steady flowing
when they come to the bars they know my
balls are mind blowing yeah you know i
grabbed them like i'm scratching this
going through the chain just to keep the
metamorphosis
rather than wack music i choose silence
every like hong kong i react to violence
uh you know i'm about to admit to y'all
cause i'm the emperor i'll be coming off
the top and leaving enemies lane shot
divide boy they'd be yelling out good
game i appreciate the support regardless
cause age man coming off the top the
hardest the yelling this is fire i'm
about to slay all you liars mac open up
your brain like the pliers
and i'm doing this for all of my peeps
man goes deep yeah y'all know they love
when i release this uh i'll be staying
up to be that's a robert has the
grand master without him it would have
been a disaster yeah and y'all know i'm
about to throw it down properly i'm
putting words together logically when
i'm finished with the mic i'ma slam it
matt goes these quantum mechanics uh and
you know i kick true facts all right
cool we gon switch it up to the boom
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
wow
wow first ever pog champs experience man
[Music]
hey yo ho
hey
gms man if you still on here i
appreciate the kind words my bro
no doubt no doubt no doubt uh yeah i'm
bout to wreck the mic i'm thinking ahead
see i'm applying chest to life i can't
only think about the next move i make
cause if i do that i might not notice
mistakes so i gotta plan on a longer
time scale so that i know that my mind
can prevail yeah i never fail and y'all
know that i'ma mention this i can't
always be stuck in that defensive i
gotta be up on the offense as well
capturing pieces off the board to excel
you know what i'm saying we can't always
be on guard we gotta find a way to push
forth and go hard yeah i'm doing me and
i will devour foes this applies to life
the queen's the most powerful and that's
a fact i'll break it down in the verse
cause the queen is the one with the womb
to give birth most power forever can
create new human life can you understand
what the i'm doing right i mean i
am here as a man and i'm proud of myself
to move forward with the plan but the
woman can open up the body to create
another body if you ask me that power is
godly so shouts into queens moving how
they
for these other rappers it be hopeless
i'm never slipping with ripping you know
i keep my focus ain't no way to act this
mac is a savage working on my chest game
putting in the practice rapping for the
west rhyme off topics i suggest not the
illness at the game don't claim to be
the best but yo i'm bout to make it
happen peace to people who recognize
that max really snapped him brand new
flavors about to get coined shout to
kwan thirst singing me who just joined
999 elo the freestyle h man came to rock
the people cause he's wild damn dude
this here is crazy these
rappers never put their work in they
staying lazy lyrically blazing you want
the real pageum shout to nutcase110 this
is amazing pawns to queens queens the
pawns back and forth i rap and scorch my
raps the torch i light the tip
excitedness is what you feeling one in
the million with these lyrics that i'm
feeling
reborn as a new man shouts to your pops
cause they finally a huge fan i get
loose with the style that's free ain't
another rapper half as wild as me i do
it off the tip of this don't even need a
pin game and that's why amber rest we
saying mac you are insane checkmate on
the game a rap you know we got that hey
yo in the beat is live i'ma drop backs
uh y'all know i be the mic burner grumpy
cat happy chat be the inspirational
learner hmac i'm in it when i kick the
bars that was nice sometimes in the game
of chess you gotta sacrifice and that's
a fact of life we hold it down
regardless i'm controlling it they're
yelling out holy the hype training
coming three minutes and 20 seconds
y'all know that my flow is infinity time
i reckon
to the 803 just threw 5 000 bits in me
get with me imma cook up lyrics like a
fricative they lining up just to witness
me uh known for putting words together
in an insane way when i'm rapping i can
probably feel the brain waves
when i'm spitting i'll be moving through
the clearing the one you hearing is the
one who practiced perseverance uh my
lyrics they be thumping and swagging
underground but i'm breaking out these
dungeons like dragons we'd be breathing
fire he's no liar you know we be the
rhyme player running from here the
rhyme say is out in minneapolis while i
be cracking through the atmosphere i
have idea to use my abilities to rap all
year i know you get the referent uh h
man coming through with the clever spit
you know that i'm ill they love how i
spill from here to brazil my lyrics is
cold they icy and chill yeah and yo over
the board i was sort of racing i gotta
practice on my chest piece coordination
ah and y'all know my voice ain't faulty
lyrically
on my drum son for real
hey we gonna do one or two more pizza
that i'ma peace out man shout out to
pogchamps that was insane yo crazy
experience crazy experience
crazy experience man
oh my god shout out to papa slanates
or is it papa's lonates
shout out to you that's incredible let's
go the gifts are flying
there's no denying
uh uh
uh yeah yeah yeah listen okay um listen
okay uh listen um i'll be coming off the
top with the songs you want i'm getting
fancy on this something like our person
it's hmac i'll be coming with the lyrics
that'll trouble you i'm winning every
game though i'm about to get the w
unless we talking chess in which case
i'm kind of a mess honestly the game had
me stressed but i still want to work on
it with robert hess yeah hoping he can
come through and be the guest up in my
crib one day yeah i'm a wholesome on my
enemy you know i'm about to close in
i'll be working at rapids vocational and
the way that i rhyme is
sensational shout outs to xav coming
through with mad gifts five tier ones
man you know he's working magic 69 and
you know that it's a meme might be
spitting fire even when i'm sleeping in
my dreams make you say hey go ahead and
press play h mac be the one to hold it
down all day you're the gmc thanks for
saying that shout out to the mart dan no
steady laying back doing what i'm
feeling grand master master but
ceremonies double master y'all know that
hairy homie really gets loose with the
raps every time i'm spitting they
producing the clap so do bout to snap
y'all know he's pogba's insane all these
other rappers get off of the game this
is lyrical chess and i stay like a step
ahead and you know i'm about to rap till
the day i'm dead uh a lot of love from
saudi arabia i'm blazing ya i'm doing it
proudly you shout to my homie that's
dancing under the palm tree while you
kick the lyrical thunder i'm strong g i
know that i picture a picture i'm a
fixture faster than twister nah shout
the twister he's faster than everyone
yeah i spit filth every time that i get
it done make you wonder never get laid
asunder i'm about to pump you up even if
i plunder y'all know when i spit it'll
be dope
that's a slippery slope yeah and you
know i came to truly flow imma do my
duty brought up in the studio i moved
like yu-gi-oh i really got the power so
check the viscosity h mac about to
change the game mode probably probably
putting together you know i'm live
everybody around the planet feeling the
vibe yeah i'm chilling and i'm saying
this is amazing every time they be
spilling yo the kid is straight blazing
do what i feel and i'm making y'all
believers i'mma kill you dead homie i'm
the grim reaper but slim y'all that look
like slam shady that's for eminem he's
getting hella lyrical got everybody
trembling but then again i'm colder than
the winter wind from the moment that i'm
entering man you know they will remember
him burn them in the embers them dip
from the same h mac y'all know i be
spitting for fiends they just wanna hear
it they say you the man wanna hit a real
we're gonna stand back cause i'ma
come and flip flows i know that we sick
bro
ready to slam hold up i'll make it
happen and y'all know i'm about to run
yeah through the bow test gambit bring
the thunder h man you know that i'm
really bout to spark right i'ma caught
him in the cave like the dark knight he
just keeps on going he just keeps on
flowing i got more skills that i must
show them uh people thinking the way
that i perform i'll be peeling lyrics
from the soul sounding like an orange
let me get activity feed that's what i
need cause people might be giving gibson
ray to me oh hello i'ma go against the
grain i'm the rebel guy matter of fact
i'm staring rappers down with the devil
eye best
love it from the moment that my raps are
released yeah shout out to jacob and
christian they tapping it harry mack all
my fans you know i'ma rap for them shout
out to my channel lebron plugging the
discord fam hmac y'all know i'm the man
god damn people in the chat how are you
feeling they gon feel my vibes from here
while you're out to new zealand shout
out to underpants coming through give to
five pizza everybody watching me getting
live i just played my first official
chess match honestly if you ask me i
bless that i know i lost both games two
in a row but still yo i was working and
doing beautiful bro so let me put it up
for y'all while i wander shouts to kanye
cuz he just dropped under i haven't had
a chance to really listen to it yet but
i know the way it gets down he probably
pressed a threat hmac y'all don't know
where you're about to turn my song
spitting fire just to get you higher
than the pawn cloud hmac y'all know i'm
speeding it the way i do my lyrical
skills ain't intermediate i'm advanced
take a chance you know i'll be going
where they never go i'm a student and
that is
i know they gonna hate on me though but
i don't wanna hear it cause you know i'm
going crazy much love going out to
warrior ac 25. glad we finally got you
on the stream to see you with your
family it truly was a dream shout to
calgary coming through with four one
four and a four month five you know
they're about to take that dive hmac man
you know this there is domination i'll
be waiting i'll be thinking pick the
contemplation let's rhyme
[Music]
all right y'all
that's it for today man
oh we're gonna send this hype train
through and then and then i'm gonna pee
so couple more bars then i gotta bounce
i gotta pack day
thank y'all so much for watching my
first official
oh my god the original black pepper
shout out to the original black pepper
just gifted ten tier one subs my god
thank you
shout out to uh
iris
salute i hope i said that right thank
you for the stuff kyle glor give them
five come on thank you
hop g20 thank you for the resub k copper
tone
10 tier 1 subs my god k coppertone going
crazy wonder pants with the five sucks
everybody's gifting crazy subs and doing
all types of miraculous things um we saw
the hype train through we did what we
came to do
twitch you know i'm doing this for you
let's go
all right y'all uh i can't stay i can't
stay i gotta pack day lots of stuff on
the plate but thank y'all
and we're live pogchamps four presented
by coinbase is back we have our first
rematch of pog champs for a match that
took place from pogchamps 2 a while ago
um
[Music]
connor cutie thanks for being
here i'm i'm a little confused cutie
looks different
well i i wanted to be a woman gm today
and i thought what what better way
than to be alex botez herself wow
yeah
yeah okay well you you be careful with
the queens uh alex botes because those
are really tricky creatures i've heard
i've heard that i should avoid i should
watch my queen not give it away right
not give away my queen it's what i do
yes yes actually no it depends on what
you're into like you can you can give
away your queen too it depends
yeah yeah i think the good thing is i
think connor will do it before i have an
opportunity
probably
connor so i know you played cutie before
and the score was 2-1 you have your
chance for the rematch
how are you feeling going into this well
2-1 there doesn't doesn't tell the
entire story it was a very close to one
it was uh
it was a good game um i didn't get as
much practice as i wanted to this week i
was a little uh busy unfortunately but
uh
you know uh as they said i'm a bit of a
prodigy so let's hope it uh shows off
today it's because i looked at your
account and your last game was may 5th
you know i did a great on that match
have you have you played it all since
yeah i mean i played like i did like the
lessons and stuff
well maybe maybe he also has a secret
account you're the secret account connor
yeah and i know my all uh my all is kind
of going right right right right right
right right
you're all to count okay so if i lose i
should feel really really bad about
myself yes very much i play multiple
times a week
beauty you can't lose in this cosplay
you can't i usually don't pick favorites
as a commentator but
you're making it very difficult right
now with the cosplay
uh connor you have do you have a purple
shirt maybe you could be danny yeah
you i bet you have one of these twitch
partner shirts they're they're really
cool
they never gave me one
nope
oh well
um they should give you one connor
because your consciousness is amazing
i can't send you twitch sag but i can
send you all the chess.com swag you want
what do you want
uh all of it all of it as many clothes
as i can get i'll send all of it to you
um
i i don't even know where to go with
this interview i don't know why we're
really excited to have you guys playing
i'm focused i'm ready to play the game
yeah cutie is you know coming back the
winner from last match but connor it was
closer than it actually seemed and he's
been training in his secret alternate
account you guys are good friends as
well so it always makes it a little bit
more fun when you're playing someone you
know connor and cutie good luck to both
of you it'll be fun thank you so much
but we'll see you on the other amazing
thank you thank you thank you all right
we've got connor and cutie
they're about to throw down like we said
alexandra that's that's the first
rematch of uh
of pogchamps four we've got others
coming up we know that ludwiger and mr
beast are gonna throw down has a lot of
people hype but
okay to to what's in front of me we
gotta rise above the disorder
use the command donate please to learn
more let's hit that thousand dollar goal
we don't have only one match left let's
definitely get over a thousand on the
first day there we go right on cue a
donation coming in in real time
rise above the disorder works to help
the tens of thousands of people and tons
of people suffer from mental health and
often they struggle to get access and be
able to afford it and that's what rad is
all about use the command chess.com is
donating a hundred thousand dollars
matching your donations and we hope that
you uh will contribute over the next
couple weeks i also want to just give a
big shout out again remind you before
our last match starts that just.coms
pogchamps is presented by coinbase all
you have to do is go to coinbase.com
chess you can earn while you learn five
dollars in crypto like i said if you're
a real person and you verify your
account then you get free money that's
probably the best deal i've ever heard
in my life
and i hope that you take advantage of it
go to coinbase.com chess today all right
we're going to let cutie get set up or
should i say alexandra botez uh
doppelganger um i'm gonna let connor
focus on his cat
i feel like she's doing it better i'm
really impressed but yeah absolutely we
will get to their games very soon
and we will be right back with the last
match of the day the first day of
pogchamps 4 not over yet don't go
anywhere we will return
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much
more learn more at coinbase.com
chess
[Music]
so
and we are back here with pogchamps 4
presented by coinbase we have alexander
botes commentating alexander botez
playing
um connor eats pants who does not
actually eat pants if you're wondering
we have checked he's he has a very good
diet it's safe
um alexander yeah
well i
man i'm still so impressed with cutie's
cosplay she killed it and i saw that she
even has the overlays on her chat just
fully committing cutie is always just
upping the content on every single show
she does she's like one of those
students who who wouldn't just get an a
she would get an a plus you know what i
mean and not only that like it looks
like she went and found the perfect fake
plant i'm pretty sure i've seen that
fake plant and you're in andrea's
apartment
whatever well we got some fake plants
behind us too we can't keep the real
ones alive but
yeah she nailed it connor he looks super
focused
um
he is a little bit of the underdog here
because he's slightly lower rated and
you know it's hard to play against
someone that you know you've lost to
before psychologically
well and cutie was talking a little bit
of smack saying like hey i've looked at
your account you haven't played since
may 5th what are you doing
yeah he's like i've been doing the
lessons
um
all right well we did cross one he does
kind of look like megan fox right now
yeah she does she's sorry i was reading
the chat
that's like pre-transformers megan fox
new connor was the freaking stratford
are you kidding me
oh they started
caro khan here we go
we crossed the thousand dollars raised
for charity on day one way to go whoever
chess.com is matching up to a hundred k
so
if you uh
you want to make that doughnut i don't
want my time on this tax write-off
we're gonna match up to a hundred
thousand dollars let's raise 200k total
that is an awesome cause
okay what is going on here i don't
remember the i don't remember the karo
khan now
sorry levy
all right there was a knight on the side
but it did not get taken that's okay
and uh here
cutie is attacking conor's queen
bishop e2 looks real oh i spent all my
time on the stafford um
this should be two would be good but she
boates gan uh he boat has gambited oh my
god cutie called it she said he would
botes gambit
yep
oh my gosh
oh my gosh i guess
everyone's cosplaying me oh my gosh no
wait
we have a moist critical moment no it
didn't happen
i feel like cutie had mercy there i feel
like she saw a checkmate in one and
didn't take it
yeah
[Music]
that was brutal
uh but connor is still alive here
so that is a good sign um
and now he might see the threat on v2
and move his king over and at least not
get forked
that's that's not a bad move he's
attacking the queen twice but
now he has to see rook be one
yeah you gotta see rook b1
um
i
sorry i just my heart stopped beating
for a minute there when we had knight
takes up two checkmate on the board
yeah no that's that's fair maybe we can
uh show it after this game if anybody
missed it there was a checkmate and it
would have been in less than 10 moves
but cutie played a little bit quickly
and missed it
conor moves his rook to safety which is
great had he moved it to b1 it would
have been a little bit better rook b1 is
still a great move right now but it's
hard to think of moving the same piece
twice yep
connor does look very focused though he
does he looks super focused
also looking fresh
like he just showered just looking fresh
he just celebrated a birthday a couple
days ago
absolutely he's a young talented
streamer what did he turn like what 17
wow
wow wow
uh this is this is a nice move
queen uh knight a4 it's not necessarily
the most accurate move but he is
attacking the queen and putting pressure
on the bishop at the same time um and at
least
it keeps things interesting but i am
worried that cutie is also going to play
knight takes f2
and uh you know gobble up
the rook in the future but what if she
forgets and leaves her queen on b2 it
would be double botez gambit in one game
no double botes the double protest
let's see it i
i know the cosplay ah there you go there
you go
no bothers gambit she's not committed to
the character danny you know i would
have given my queen there yeah seriously
what kind of acting is this we're going
to call her out on that
yeah what's on what's going on um
oh apparently there's an ad getting an
ad from cutie
we're going to subscribe to cutie
cinderella we just got outed as not
being subscribing to subscribe to our
show come on chester.com please go sub
to cutie cinderella right now we're
subbing to her right now our team is
subbing so we got a lot of things
rolling in our production here using
amazing tools and we will subscribe
there you go there you go
now that might be the eternal moment of
the game people might want to type
eternal for that because that's a
clipable thing that was accidental
beauty is going to be pissed
i mean this is kind of a cool ad they're
doing gymnastics yeah let's bring up the
full ad here check it out real quick
what is this an ad here for
okay oh there that's the famous gymnast
oh forgot
yeah
all right there's cutie
that was the worst thing that's ever
happened on a podcamp right there
hey hey geico if you're watching this
and you want me to bow test gambit and
then put geico over it i'm all for it
you know just hit me up
hello okay well cutie is very close to
checkmating here so she's attacking the
rook on c1 but there are no immediate
checkmates but i i just i don't want i
don't want connor to get his hopes down
you know yeah
well we're going to work on some chess i
hooked up with conor on discord
yesterday
we're going to work on some chess this
is not you know i know this is a rough
start for conor but
he will not be
if this is this is not good connor
connor is conor is smart he's a quick
learner this is just him being a little
bit rusty and cutie having more
experience cutie is playing incredibly
and honestly she's made so much progress
since the first fog channel she really
had i mean cutie cutie dark horse could
win this whole thing like no joke i mean
i know that
her non-platonic partner ludwig is also
in the event um
and he's he's still a better chess
player
that would be amazing scripted okay now
we have checkmate on the board i feel
like cutie's gonna see it
um connor said he's a prodigy and i'm
gonna i'm gonna take him up on that
we're gonna work on his chest
ooh hmm
okay
yeah that was actually a weird choice
[Music]
oh missed the mate but still a good go
here
whatever i don't know what i'm doing i
can't find a pretty check so i'm just
gonna do
um
i'm just gonna come take this
i can't find a pretty check because i
haven't castled i haven't got my rooks
out so i'm just gonna go boop
and then he can take that
i'll just clean up the board
i'm not as cool as i thought i was
not the worst strat at least you know
it's gonna be a guaranteed win
she's not reading her chat she has chat
in emote only mode
[Music]
i actually want him to take that because
i wanted to bring out my bishop without
having to move my knight or rook i want
to move out my rook
[Music]
okay
great thanks god
he's enjoying it why even say yes connor
connor why even say yes uh
hey connor do you want to drive dog
champs yeah it sounds like fun
oh my god he doesn't practice it all
cutie is there's no chance savage
there's no chance he has practiced
at all
let me castle for shits and gigs hey she
even has the trash talk down though i
will say she's killing it
but um connor i hope he's not
discouraged
yeah take that i don't care
why wouldn't you take that
what are you doing oh my god
wait i don't know who i think i am i
can't do a
king a queen knight
i can't do it why are you not taking
that night conor
okay i'm just gonna end it
actually
i'm sorry for being a psychopath prior
to this
what are you doing
i don't know what he thinks he's doing
but is so strange
this is such weird behavior
go here
it's the only place you can go
okay
now go here
wait this is checkmate right yeah
okay
i don't know connor i feel bad
i feel bad
well that was a
beauty
beauty took almost every piece on the
way to a victory i guess her pog champs
for uh
pogchamps 4 campaign is off to a good
start
she did
um you know conor had a little bit of a
rough start yeah but
last time after he started you know
brushing off the rust he was able to
pick things up pretty quickly and hey
cutie clean it up she did well and she
was also having a fun time while doing
it so congratulations to her for the
first game all right well we'll um we'll
get back uh very soon uh before before
uh any anything else happens don't go
anywhere we're gonna take a very quick
break before game two between cutie
cinderella and connor eats pants
pogchamps four presented by coinbase
continues in just a minute
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
and we're back with pogchamps 4 and you
know who else is back all of the bots uh
in fact for the first time we launched
uh the pog champion bots the voyboy hafu
sardosh and who knows we'll be joining
them after pogchamps 4.
if you had a chance to pair one bot
versus another with live computer style
trash talk who would you pair together
alexandra
ooh
well xqc is really funny when he's
talking trash so absolutely xqc and it'd
have to be somebody who actually reacts
to his trash talk um
ludwig would react his trash talk but
ludwig would be too high rated so maybe
xqc versus versus pokeman would be fun
to see
yeah or if we could make xqc's bot
stronger than sardosh's bought i'd love
to see that go down or just really
really cool yes yeah sardoche might want
a refund if you do that yeah
all right um
let's remind everybody too that while
you're watching pogchamps and you get
the bug and want to get better you
should download the learn chest with dr
wolf at
right now we have a one week free trial
on ios and android download the app get
your free trial start learning with your
favorite new doctor the doctor's in the
house get your dr wolf out um
we
want to remind everybody of the schedule
real quick coming up for the rest of the
event uh obviously today is august 29th
we will be back here tomorrow at 12 p.m
pacific time
and we are switching and reminding you
of the schedule for uh
just some very quick unfortunate news
uh conor eats pants as an urgent matter
that he needed to deal with uh in his uh
in his life so obviously we wish him the
absolute best it's unfortunate but we
will not have a second game here between
conor and cutie uh at least not now
alexander we will we will confer with
the players and decide what they're up
for
before making any final decisions about
the match
so we might have a game two at a at a
two b schedule time
we might not but we wish conor out
obviously the absolute best with the
urgent situation that came up while he
was playing the match actually so uh we
wish him the best
yeah that is a tough situation to be in
but um we'll let him get to that and we
can talk about what game is coming up
tomorrow we have three super exciting
matches um let's start off with fundy
versus tech tone uh box box versus minx
and ludwig versus mr beast danny which
one are you most excited for i think
everyone has the you know jimmy ludwig
battle there at the end of the day
circled and um
we'll we'll see we'll see what the
rematch remember if you didn't follow
bog champs three they threw ten thousand
dollars down on a single game uh we'll
see if jimmy's up to do that
um well jimmy does like donating money
so yeah he
just like donating money
and i've been doing some chess with
jimmy but we need him we need him to you
know maybe he likes to bet to motivate
himself so we'll see what happens versus
ludwig but to the first match i think
fundy versus tech tone is is low-key of
gonna be a really fun really fun match
fundy has been grinding a ton
and he's been doing lessons with
everybody but techtone was uh was kind
of a surprise new chess addict in
tournament r2 which happened about a
month ago so
the anime community will be cheering him
on um and then you've got box box who
uh against justin minx i think box box
albert's definitely the favorite i i
know that minx has been working on her
game your thoughts about that matchup
well box box um was so strong in the
first pogchamps one he went even to 1400
rating and minx she's been learning
really quickly but she is newer to the
game so she's certainly an underdog
hopefully we can do some training with
her leading up to the game i mean you're
always going to have these first round
pairings being a little bit more uneven
before we see players split off into the
two different brackets but it's also
really a good chance for players to get
experience playing somebody higher rated
than them and trying not to tilt
yeah and boxbox just won a chess event
we had a few weeks ago against ludwig
the winner stays event that we hold once
a month where the winner stays and if
you win three matches in a row you get
three grand and ludwig was one win away
from an extra 3k and box box showed up
and broke his heart so if we had a
rematch of box box lug wig at some point
during pog champs that would be brutal
um
yeah brutal but i would love to see it
and ludwig is you know gaining rating
and he's been playing more chess than
box box so maybe he'll have his rematch
yeah no i think that's going to be a fun
one to watch out for obviously ludwig
just exacted revenge on sardosha
pogchamps 3 rematch and twitch rivals on
thursday so and all kinds of exciting
stuff ahead day one is surprisingly
coming to a close here a little faster
than we thought but like we said our
absolute best wishes with with conor uh
we will let the fans know what happens
with the remaining the remaining game in
this particular match um
alexander and andre are about to throw
throw up their stream right after this
so everyone should tune in to them yes
what's up what's on the docket today
just a bunch of bow test gambits
well we were going to do some in real
life chess streaming but i don't think
we'll have time to set it up so what
we're going to do instead is we're going
to be playing some high energy chess
splits at our computer it'll be really
fun uh you know the chat is always super
excited after pogchamp so we'll be there
hopefully hosting a fun after party
all right we'll join alexandra and
andrea we will see you tomorrow august
30th for day two of pogchamps make sure
you tune in obviously we've got that
huge marquee match up at the end of the
day ludwig and mr beast so
until then thank you again to our
sponsors eternal and coinbase please
again continue to consider donating i'm
super pumped about what we can do over
the next couple weeks for rad
and on that note thanks to the whole
team working hard we are going to wrap
this thing up we will see you tomorrow
for day two of pogchamps four right at
12 noon pacific time
[Music]
so
you